So Leute, worum geht's?
Soll ich euch mal was sehr trauriges sagen?
Mein Amazon Fire HD 8 hat Apps wieder deaktiviert, die ich schon längst deaktiviert hatte.
Was dazu geführt hat, dass ich jetzt massig Amazon Ad Spam auf meinem Tablet habe.
Ich muss erstmal wieder alle Apps deaktivieren.
Und der Fehler, den ich gemacht habe, ist, mich bei Amazon Video einzuloggen.
Das heißt, wenn man sein Amazon Tablet deep-loadet und ent-Amazonifiziert hat
und man loggt sich bei einer Amazon App einmalig ein, dann muss man das Ganze nochmal machen.
Das ist natürlich Big Brain von Amazon.
Was sagt?
Was ziemlich sagt.
Was kostet eigentlich Feuerwerk so?
Ich meine, ich mache kein Feuerwerk, aber was kostet denn das eigentlich aktuell so?
Feuerwerk, Set, Aldi.
Keine Ahnung, was kostet das denn?
Ist das teuer geworden?
Wow.
Easy.
227 Euro.
Ah, yes.
1712 Euro.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Excellent Price.
Mein Chat ist übrigens gerade kaputt, ne?
Ich sag's nur.
So, jetzt geht er wieder.
Alter, ist das teuer?
Was ist das?
Warum kostet das 30 Milliarden Euro?
Achso, das ist irgend so ein Profi-Zeug oder so.
Okay.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist ganz schön teuer, oder?
Das ist ganz schön teuer.
Moment.
Ah, anstatt dass ich selbst Feuerwerk mache...
Also, ich mache ja kein Feuerwerk.
Aber anstatt dass ich selbst Feuerwerk mache, kann man sich den großen Feuerwerksimulator kaufen.
Das ist natürlich auch excellent.
Wir brauchen uns den Veko-Feuerwerksimulator.
Gibt's davon?
Ich brauche davon unbedingt Screenshots.
Ist die mal...
Na ja, gut.
die vor allem die häuser sehen sehen absolut hoch detailliert aus ja das ist die musik dieser
realismus ja huge aber noch tour lüfter drauf beste top tender story games von 2019 das gucken
wir uns dann alles an silvester anders zeugs manchmal copy pasten silvester gucken wir uns
an was es für gescheite games gibt nächstes jahr und was dieses jahr so abgekackt ist vielleicht
nicht alles an silvester rechtlich so früh erzählen würde immer so in dem träger kann
man notizprogramm nicht starten was mich sehr wundert warum gibt es so wir fangen mal an wir
fangen wir ein bisschen was zu gucken und zwar als um einstieg gucken wir uns die top battlefield
die top place der battlefield top place an also das ist so richtig top play inception
ja der eichler ich sag ja das kann ich kann mir das kaum kaum vorstellen
dass er wirklich da sein komisches feiber ding überall verwendet aber gucken wir uns mal die
top place der top place also zur einstellung ist battlefield 1 2
was okay battlefield physik beste
hoffe das sind alle battlefield weil ich meine das heißt ach moment es ist best of
2000 battlefield 5 top place will nicht die battlefield 5 top place hat er auch eine hatte
auch eine 2019 top battlefield place
ach nee ist doch oder dann ist alles battlefield 5 das ist ja doof da habe ich gar keinen bock zu
gucken das bild wie drei darf gucken gucken wir lieber battlefield 3 top place bevor wir uns
battlefield 5 top place angucken was passiert ich habe so ein glück gekriegt haben wir das schon
gesehen haben wir das schon gesehen es kommt mir irgendwie sehr bekannt vor
und check out those nostalgic titles of really awesome gameplay still to be found on those great modern
jscht für die fünf nicht so beliebt ist bei mir nicht die spielzeit netto
intro wie moose naja der hat natürlich den big brain name
das kennen wir oder das haben wir doch kommt mir bekannt vor
in
Ja, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Jetzt ist es aber langsam eng.
Wir haben schon alles geguckt.
Dann gucken wir uns jetzt was altes Battlefield 3 an.
Also was ist alt?
Drei, vier Monate.
Das beste Map ist voll Terran Highway.
Übelst underrated Map.
Ist eines meiner absoluten Lieblingsmaps.
In den letzten Wochen.
Und dieser erste Clip von NCIS ist einfach verrückt.
Wir werden später ein bisschen mehr von NCIS sehen in diesem Episode.
Aber nächstes Mal ist es Oyun Senin mit einem unglaublichen Prediktions-TV.
Ne, da war schon ein bisschen Glück dabei.
Busy.
Nur ganz klar ist Busy.
Aber da war schon auch, das war schon prediktiert.
Das war nicht einfach mal random geschossen.
Nächstes Mal ein Clip von JShark mit zwei Perspektiven und einer tollen Reaktion.
Ist das Terran?
Ja, ja, ja.
Eskalieren alle.
So einen Scheiß kannst du halt echt nur in Battlefield machen, ja.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man sowas überhaupt in Battlefield 1 und 5 machen kann.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert, hä?
What?
Das war, das war, das war Glück.
War auch eine coole Map.
Das war nicht ganz so, was ich erwartet habe, als ich den Clip erst gesehen habe.
Das ist ein Epoch, nur im Battlefield-Moment.
Das war in der letzten Sekunde.
Danke, Mann.
Alter.
Die Leute wieder.
Oh, meine Güte.
So.
Ich bin der krasse Sniper.
Ich sitze auf dem Hochhaus.
Und kriege von der Welt rum, rum, nix mit.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist das.
Das genauso wie dieser Typ, ja.
Genauso stelle ich mir den 0815-Sniper-Noob vor.
Genauso wie dieser Typ, ja.
Moment.
Springt er jetzt wieder in den...
Oh, geil.
Der springt.
Der springt wieder in den Chat rein.
Das war natürlich nice.
Das war...
Das war richtig cool.
Dass der Chat genau an der Stelle wieder runterkommt, wo er den Typ killt.
Das ist nice.
Das ist wieder sowas, wo ich mir denke, okay.
War das Setup?
Oder war das, war das halt einfach Riesenglück?
Das war auf jeden Fall nice.
Okay, sellout.
Überspringen wir mal.
Okay.
M16.
Erstmal, erstmal schön OP-Gun.
Aber warum nicht?
Boah!
Das war halt das Coole an Battlefield 3, dass du durch die Gegner durchsprayen konntest.
Sonst hätte das überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Und jetzt sauber ein bisschen mit der Magnum drauf, ja voll.
Das ist halt einfach nice zu gucken, ne?
Gegner.
Der Schneiber wieder nix gecheckt, ey.
Aber du brauchst dumme Gegner.
Das geht gar nicht anders.
Ja.
Ich fand das cool.
Kid-Switched und fand ich in Bad Company 2 richtig geil.
Weggesprayt.
Das wird dann der Schneiber-Typ da hinten, der nicht in der Lage ist, ihn zu treffen, irgendwie.
Ja, stimmt, Eax, du hast schon ganz schön oft durchgeschossen, ne?
Und manchmal hast du auch Sachen getroffen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, warum hat er das jetzt genau gehittert?
Irgendwie tatsächlich.
Teilweise 5 Sekunden später.
Aber Battlefield 3 war halt einfach nice.
Mittlerweile muss man sagen, glaube ich, ich hab ja schon eine Weile nicht mehr gespielt, ist Battlefield 4 auch richtig gut.
Aber ich hab keinen Bock mal wieder mit dem Uralt-Spiel anzufangen jetzt.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr Leute, es sind ja gerade Service-Games, sind ja voll angesagt, ne?
So nach dem Motto, wir bringen jetzt ein Game raus, was wir dann über 3 Jahre updaten, guckt euch Rainbow Six.
Oder sowas in die Richtung an.
Ich hätte echt keine Probleme, die würden ein ordentliches, und ich betone nicht auf ordentliches, Battlefield rausbringen.
Und das ein bisschen mehr für Service-Gamifizieren.
Weil ich hätte mir bei Battlefield 3 beispielsweise gerne, also hätte ich gerne mehr und hab mir gewünscht, dass da länger mehr Content kommt.
Also länger in der Zeit her und auch insgesamt mehr Content.
Und bei Battlefield 4 irgendwo auch, ja.
Das, da hätte ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit.
Das können die ruhig machen.
Das Problem ist nur, ich hab keinen Bock, das mit Battlefield 5 zu machen.
Sollen sie es mit Bad Company 3 machen und dafür in Ordnung...
Aber erst, das Base-Game muss halt gut sein.
Wenn das Base-Game nicht gut ist, bringt einem noch so viel Service-Game-Geschichte nix.
Also generell bringt einem Service-Game ein bisschen weniger Geld in der Tasche in der Regel.
Aber sieht man an Anthem, Anthem hat Base-Game-Crap und alles, was danach gekommen ist, ist jetzt halt auch nicht dadurch gut.
Weil ich meine, wenn das Base-Game schon crap ist...
Was willst du dann mit inhalten, ja?
Dann brauchst du dann wie bei No Man's Sky 85.000 Jahre, bis das Game halbwegs taugt.
...Rush, because things just get really, really hectic.
And often you have to switch out to your secondary and the Rex is just a beast.
I've never seen a title quite like it.
That thing will just tear through people.
And of course he's got his M98B for some close-range stuff.
Well, you gotta be accurate and he definitely is.
And towards the end of this clip you will see...
Warum hat das... das ist jetzt wieder so...
Warum hat das Messer getroffen? Das Messer war irgendwo am Arsch der Welt.
...but he is killing them so quickly that I can't really blame them.
Ja, deswegen muss das Game von Anfang an richtig gut sein, dass die Player-Base quasi geil ist auf mehr Content und halt auch da bleibt.
Was in Battlefield 3 ja funktioniert hat, trotz jetzt nicht soo viel Content.
Also 9.
Die raffen gar nix, nee.
Die raffen null.
Das sind doch nicht mal Weihnachts-Noobs in so alten Games.
Das sind einfach Kack-Noobs.
Durch und durch.
Ja, No Man's Sky hat die Kurve gekriegt.
Oh, er rätzt.
Das darf das Video von ihm zeigen. Das ist ja alles gut.
Nee, ich hab den noch nicht gekauft. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich das wirklich mache.
Oh, nice. Schön reingesprayt. Und wieder Gegner, die nix gecheckt haben. Aber das muss so sein.
Ja.
Erstmal schön zwischen den Getränken.
Leider down.
Ich hab gedacht, es geht jetzt nochmal weiter.
Aber das ist halt das Geile an den alten Battlefield-Teilen oder an den älteren Battlefield-Teilen gewesen.
Du konntest durchaus ganz okay sein die restliche Runde.
Das war dann aber jetzt nicht so das Heile.
Aber manchmal hast du halt einfach so richtig krasse Dinger gehabt, wo du dann um die Ecke gelaufen bist.
Und das haben alle Gegner weggeguckt.
Du hattest eine LMG und es standen 20 Gegner vor dir gefühlt.
Und dann haben alle nicht hingeguckt und du hast angefangen...
Du hast das leer gesprayt und fast alles gekillt.
War das ne Pickup-Waffe oder konnte man die ausrüsten in Battlefield 4?
War das Pickup oder konnte man das ausrüsten?
Pickup.
Das war schon eines der Punkte, die ich an Battlefield 4 doof fand mit den Pickup-Waffen.
Na? Laser da jetzt in Typwerk? Ne.
Hä?
Das war halt bisschen Prediction und ziemlich viel Glück.
Ja gut, das war halt pures Glück.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal den Gegner an.
Ich mein, wie beknackt...
Wie beknackt muss man eigentlich sein...
Jetzt...
Jetzt, Achtung...
Anstatt auf den Gegner zu schießen, den Defi rauszuholen und mein Team wieder zu beleben.
Wie...
Das... Das... Das... Pain... Pain Champ.
Das tut einfach weh.
Einfach auf den Gegner schießen und gut vergewesen. Er hat keine Chance gehabt.
Er hat sich grad mit jemand anderem beschäftigt.
Aber ne, erstmal dann den Defi rausfuddeln und direkt vor der Nase wiederbeleben.
Ja, dem geht die Muni aus wahrscheinlich. Keine Ahnung, was der vorhatte.
Aber gut, ohne Gegner, die mithelfen, klappt sowas halt nicht.
Das Video hat ganz huge Bitrate grade.
Das wär so ne Serie, die würd ich auch gerne machen, ey.
Irgendwie... Weiß nicht...
Battlefield 3 und 4 Top Plays?
So voll random einfach nur im Jahr 2020?
Einfach nur im Jahr 2020, so.
Hot Top Plays? No, nee.
Weiß nicht.
Auf dem Server spiel ich auch öfters.
Wenn ich denn... Wenn ich denn... Also, na...
Öfters ist... Bisschen übertrieben.
Jetzt wird er erstmal Crossborder.
Haha, und jetzt wieder einsteigen!
Er hat aber versucht... Er hat versucht, den Typ rauszusnipen und wieder einzusteigen.
Aber das Wiedereinsteigen hat nicht funktioniert. Aber trotzdem geil.
Ist das Starfox?
Ui!
Ah, nice!
Aiden Game Clips is next.
Ist das Starfox or not?
I don't think so.
Just lucky. Watch it again in slow motion.
Only the one kill.
Only the one kill with the Scout Elite.
Slow motion mit 5 FPS... Oh Gott!
Ich... Ich seh... Ich hab jetzt... Ich seh vor lauter Bildern nichts, was passiert, ey.
Moving on. Prodigy Wrecks. Battlefield 4 and a long range SMAW.
Gets a bit lucky as he misses the initial shot. But still, they all count.
Okay, das war auch sehr glücklich jetzt.
The second clip he sent in is on Firestorm in the T90. Fires across the map and gets himself an epic kill.
Das war schon Absicht, aber auch wahnsinnig viel Glück wieder dabei.
Next up a clip from Klaus. No origin of this one, but it's still an epic RPG-Kill.
Aber das ist die... Also ich muss sagen, das ist die... advancedeste Schreibweise von Klaus.
Die ich je gesehen habe, ey.
Klaus!
Ubuntu Klaus!
Hä?
Oh.
Ach, der hat einen gekillt. Okay, das hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Na gut.
Die haben wahrscheinlich die ganze Runde nichts anderes gemacht da oben.
Two more clips also sent in from S9. This one is across the map on Langkang Dam with the SMAW.
Check out that accuracy on that enemy chopper.
Die ganze Woche, ja. Wahrscheinlich die ganze Woche.
Schon wieder.
Extremely long range.
Schon wieder. Das ist den gleichen Typ an der gleichen Stelle.
Die haben wahrscheinlich wirklich, wie der Erk sagt, die ganze Runde in Spawn geschossen und gehofft, dass wir was treffen.
Heh.
Da stehen sie auch da mit der Munikiste.
Ich seh nix.
Okay.
Also, dass der da hingeflogen ist, da hab ich schon ganz schön Glück dabei.
Ah, Battlefield-Physik.
Oh, nice.
Aber halt auch Glück ohne Ende. Aber nice.
So Sachen sind immer cool.
Das hat er auch jetzt drei Monate probiert.
Bam.
Nice.
Und wieder einsteigen.
Oh, cool.
Das ist immer cool, wenn das klappt.
Das ist immer nice zu sehen.
So.
Scheiße auf Realismus, oder?
Viel besser.
Ich spiel das nicht, dass es realistisch ist.
Der ist reingepfloppt.
Von hinten.
Fecht gehabt.
Huge.
Das ist Battlefield 3, oder?
So blau wie das ist.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Und zu spielen.
Aber das ist ja schon nice.
Das ist einfach.
Geil zu gucken, Battlefield 3 Gegner wegzusprayen.
Ich finde auch die Sounds,
wenn du die Gegner killst bei Battlefield 3 teilweise
richtig geil.
Und erstmal der Red Strain läuft an.
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn die Gegner wüssten, was abgeht,
würden solche Clips ja auch nicht gehen.
Nice knowledge of where the enemy players are gonna be
and some really nice hit reg.
I wish we had some of that back in Battlefield 5.
And then, of course,
the .44 Magnum
with those satisfying headshots.
Damn.
Headshot fand ich schon immer übel schwierig
in Battlefield.
After math, I think it's epicenter.
Not exactly certain.
My Battlefield 3 map knowledge is a bit shaky these days.
But the AN-94
is a weapon that I really like
and love watching.
A nice clip, this.
Lots of kills.
Sieht aus wie epicenter.
Könnte auch...
Oder ist das doch nicht epicenter?
Doch, sieht aus wie epicenter.
Aber, hm.
Gefällt es sich nicht an, was es sonst sein könnte?
Nee, das ist nicht epicenter.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, wie die Map heißt.
Nee, Talamarck war es nicht.
Talamarck, da habe ich auch dran gedacht.
Talamarck ist mehr gelb.
Ja.
Oder vielleicht war es auch Talamarck, das...
Der sagt auch bei jedem Clip das gleiche, der Typ.
Äh, was geht mit der Musik ab jetzt?
Was mache ich mit den Punkten?
Einfach ausgeben.
Kennst du Equa?
Ja, einer der wenigen Leute,
die ich tatsächlich sowohl von YouTuber als auch persönlich kenne.
Der nächste ist ein verrückter Schock-Gun-Bach-Rage
von Charlie.
Hätte er nicht so viele.
Äh, äh, äh.
Minus 380.
Azani Palace.
Das kann sein, ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Kann ich mich noch dunkel gerade erinnern.
So, Hydraten, 6 Monate.
Dankeschön.
Pock.
Ja, Leiter macht der Battlefield 5.
Und Battlefield 5 gucke ich mir nicht gerne an.
Der ging durch hier.
Geht der immer noch weiter?
Was ich mich frage immer, wenn ich sowas sehe.
Hat dieses...
Hat dieses kurz in die Ironsides reinzoomen?
Hat das wirklich was für die Accuracy gebracht?
Oder war das einfach nur Angewohnheit,
die man so hatte?
Ja, mache ich.
Mache ich.
Black Mesa hat die Xen-Levels.
Das müssen wir uns unbedingt angucken.
Nee, Battlefield 5 sieht gut aus.
Aber ich mag Battlefield 5 an sich nicht.
Vom Game.
Optisch sieht dieser Ding eh mal gut aus.
Ich könnte mir...
Ich mache mir einfach einen neuen EA-Account.
Den nenne ich OK Boomer.
Und spiele nur alte Battlefields damit.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Der ist ja mit dem Kopf quasi reingesprungen
in das Fahnenkreuz gerade.
Kann man auch Battlefield 2 spielen?
Ja, theoretisch schon.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es auch Server gibt.
Weil die haben ja den ursprünglichsten Server
jetzt abgeschaltet.
Bam.
Ihr habt einen Heli getroffen.
Jetzt regt euch mal ab.
Sorry.
Wieder eine nice Compilation.
Okay.
Also, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Was haben wir denn zu bieten?
Ich habe ein paar Videos aufgemacht, die wir gucken können.
Wir können uns die Windows-Ads von Windows 1 bis Windows 10 angucken.
Wir können uns JavaScript in just 5...
Warum habe ich das denn offen?
In 5 Minutes JavaScript.
Okay.
Worst Games of 2019.
Black Mesa Xen Review.
Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall gucken.
Worst Console Launch Ever.
Google Stadia.
Das müssen wir uns auch angucken.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Wie da rumgeschleimt...
Äh, nicht rumgeschleimt.
Rumgeflamed wird.
Sagt dir Venice Unleashed was?
Ja, aber das ist ja nie fertig geworden.
Das letzte Update ist von 4 Jahren oder so.
20 Overhyped Games.
Und wir können uns ein neues Elektro-Boom-Video angucken.
Worst Games.
Okay, wir gucken uns Worst Games an.
Und dann gucken wir uns Worst Console Launch an.
Hat der CCC schon was Interessantes hochgekleinert?
Ja, das mit der Gesundheitsakte ist ganz okay.
Aber der Vortrag...
Der Vortrag ist halt ein bisschen konfus.
Und das Bahn-Mining gestern war richtig gut.
Wie so englische Sprache bei Windows ganz einfach.
Dass wenn man Probleme hat, man einfacher nach Fehlern suchen kann.
2019 ist am Ende.
Also, wie immer, machen wir ein paar Liste, die das Beste und das Schlimmste in den Spielen dieses Jahr.
Und heute sind es leider die Schlimmsten Spiele von 2019.
Die Spiele, die wir am meisten nicht mögen.
Jetzt, achtet auf, das sind unsere persönlichen Chancen hier...
Haben wir doch...
Wir haben doch letztens schon mal eine Liste gemacht.
... wie man diese Spiele liebt.
Viele Monitore, zwei, gehen wir hier beieinander.
Was?
Was, es gab ein neues Contra?
Warum müssen die eigentlich klassische Gameserien, die eigentlich ganz gut waren, immer verkacken?
Mit irgendwelchen komischen Reboots?
Ach, war das das mit dem Panda-Bär?
War das das mit dem Panda-Bär, wo ich mich gefragt habe, warum ist da ein Panda-Bär drinne?
... in Attacks a lot, but those weapons, like, they just kind of feel like they go against Contra.
The rocket launcher lets you shoot, like, two rockets, then you gotta wait for a brief cool-down, like, what gives?
Ach so, Jet Overlay, klar.
Jet Overlay, das haben wir ja gestern ausgemacht, haben wir vergessen einzuschalten.
Jet Overlay muss sein.
... all about the chaos, and at a glance, Rogue Corps does look like that's still the case, but it just doesn't feel quite right.
And that's a massive bummer.
Also, a PC-Version also seems like a hot mess, but at once the framerate was locked at 30 FPS.
I've seen, you know, some people will defend this one, but ultimately, it's just a big, big letdown.
And honestly, it's sad, like, I feel bad for die-hard Contra fans that were expecting something more.
Again, this is Konami, you know, to expect something from Konami with an original property like that is, you know, kind of naive.
It could have been cool, but unfortunately, nope, it ain't.
Konami in 2019.
... but not an okay Contra game, you know what I mean?
Hey, folks, it's Falcon, and guess what? I'm here for number 9.
So, anyway, let's talk about Narcos Rise of the Cartels.
An action-strategy game based on the hit Netflix TV series.
Games, von denen ich im Leben noch nichts gehört hab.
... you know, the genre. Don't love it. Is this a game that I would totally savage? Not necessarily.
But if you're aware of good entries of this genre, they tend to be a little more advanced than this.
Combat is rudimentary. It's not very engaging.
AI is not the worst thing you've ever seen in your life, but it's not good.
The way they work out the turns is just excruciating.
You only get one activation per turn, which is...
I mean, like I said, if you've ever played a strategy game, probably something that's going to infuriate you.
Like, you're like, move this guy. Okay, you get to move a guy. Move this guy. Okay, you get to move...
Like, everything you do, everything you do, basically gives the opponent the advantage.
... everything you do, basically gives the opponent the advantage.
Okay, number 8. Spike Volleyball
Now, forgive us if you've heard this one. Uh, we did cover it in our previous video where we looked up the numbers of the first half...
Könnt ihr auch mal Games... Könnt ihr auch mal Games irgendwie... ... the first half of the year...
Spike Volleyball is pretty rough. There's THE Falcon Temple, but I doubt he really didn't like it.
Volleyball games are often pretty awkward, but this one definitely has the worst gap left.
The highlight of the game is that the stadium looks good. There's that, there's at least a visual gain in place...
Vor allem diese tollen Gesichtsanimationen.
Moins, Gido.
Was?
Huge Animation.
I know it's not volleyball, but just go play Windjammers instead.
Do yourself a favor.
Hey, folks, Falcon here again for number seven.
Which, if you've ever wanted to see what it looks like
when EA neglects something horrifically,
look towards FIFA 20 Legacy Edition on the Nintendo Switch.
Go ahead and look at FIFA 20 Legacy Edition on your Nintendo Switch
and then look at FIFA 19 on your Nintendo Switch.
Tell me the difference.
I'll save you the trouble.
It's the roster, that's it.
And it's not like FIFA 19 was like
the shining version of FIFA 19.
Nee, aber die müssen, die sind vertraglich verpflichtet,
ein Spiel für die Konsole zu releasen.
Ob sie das jetzt wollen oder nicht, die müssen.
Dementsprechend wird da auf den Konsolen,
wo sie keinen großen Fokus drauflegen,
wird, ich meine, FIFA ist eh schon der Cash Crap ohne Ende,
wird echt das absolut Minimalste vom Praktikant
in der Mittagspause beim Cutten programmiert.
Version of the game.
It's crappier that doesn't keep up with the mainline FIFA games
continuing to have some of the same troubles
that were fixed several games ago on other platforms.
If you like FIFA 20 on any other platform,
care about some of the features that they've added,
don't bother, they're not here.
Now over at number 6, let's get a little divisive here.
Warum müssen die das?
Weil das an den Lizenzbedingungen hängt.
Also sie sind, sie haben sich das ja gekauft
und ein Teil dieser Lizenzbestimmung ist,
dass die jede Konsole bis, frag mich nicht,
die irgendwie eine gewisse Verbreitung hat,
müssen sie an FIFA rausbringen.
Warum kackt der in der Mittagspause nicht während der Arbeitszeit?
Weil er während seiner Arbeitszeit jetzt andere FIFA programmieren muss.
Ghost Recon Breakpoint.
Now, some people are already freaking out
about us including this one,
but ultimately for us, we hashed it out
and really it was a disappointment.
This is coming from people that really kinda liked Wildlands
and Wildlands grew to be an even better game over time.
Breakpoint might be the same way,
but as of now,
as of how it launched,
it was just dull and uninspiring.
Ja, lass uns mal ein tolles Loot-System einbauen,
was keiner braucht.
Don't get it twisted though,
like it is by no means the worst game on this list.
And again, if you're playing it
and if you found a community
or if you found a friend
or you're just loving it solo,
good for you, I'm happy for you.
The shooting in this game is very competent,
you know, the movement,
everything feels there and high quality,
but ultimately we just found the same.
Ja, es fiel... es... es...
es fiel alles High-Quality,
was sie mehr oder weniger direkt vom Vorgänger übernommen haben.
The stuff the game gives you to do
is to be pretty dull, pretty boring
and really it just all felt kinda phoned in.
Does that sound terrible?
My biggest complaint with it really was that
a lot of it just felt like incomplete,
down to little things like some of the cars not having radios...
Ich hab bis heute nicht gecheckt,
ob die das Geld überwiesen haben mittlerweile für den Sellout.
Muss ich mal machen.
Nicht, dass ich's umsonst Sellout gemacht hab.
... glitches and bugs
and ultimately it seemed like a lot of people weren't the biggest...
fans of it because they kind of went back on their roadmap
and their plans for the game in the future.
I do think really this one just needed more time in the oven.
It feels like a bad Games-as-a-Service-Game.
It feels like it's designed to just, you know, be there.
Es ist designt, sinnlose Mechaniken zu haben,
dass man das upgraden kann.
Das ist ja das Aufgesetzteste überhaupt, ne?
Diese Komplimente.
Diese komischen Survival-Aspekte, die mit dem Game überhaupt nichts zu suchen haben.
... with friends, but ultimately we're still just chalking this one up
as a huge letdown for us Ghost Recon fans.
Now maybe Ubisoft can pull this car around
and really make something good out of this game.
They've done that in the past with quite a few,
so we'll see. We'll hope for the best.
Because next over at number 5 we have Mario Kart Tour.
Yes, this is that mobile Mario Kart game that came out this year,
which is another massive disappointment.
And frankly, not really what many of us...
wanted.
It's like us here, like, we do have a tolerance...
Ich glaube, es ist das erste, ich glaube, es ist das erste so richtige, ähm,
Nintendo Cash Crab Mobile Transaction Game.
Wie es bei Pokémon aussieht, weiß ich nicht, ob das da so schlimm ist,
aber da ist halt, das ist einfach nur da, um, um Microtransactions zu haben.
... in there, but Mario Kart Tour really takes the cake.
It was such a letdown and it just kind of was like doomed from the start.
Nee, das Super Mario Runner.
... we were so worried about it.
Das kann man nicht. Das kaufst du einmal und dann kannst du es spielen.
Mario Run ist gar nicht schlecht.
Chuck98, dankeschön, Twitch Prime. Big Brainsub.
Man darf ja nicht denken übrigens, ne, also wer das nicht gespielt hat,
man darf jetzt nicht denken, man fährt hier großartig.
Also, du fährst zum größten Teil automatisch.
Und du kannst auch nicht von der Strecke fallen oder so.
Das sieht nur so aus, als würde man fahren. Man fährt gar nicht wirklich.
...**амаusik, mit dem Handy in fauxfarbigemädem**
Dark väldigt serious Build,
not sorry, I forgot.
Not a lot of games are worth a five-dollar a month subscription,
let alone a really simple AI bo-t-race Mario-Kart mobile game,
filled with gacha elements.
Basically, it was just all the free-to-play mobile game stuff you really hate was crammed into a Mario Kart Game.
... I do not know why, we were hoping for more,
you know, Nintendo has had outings before with monetizations.
sie, aber Mario Kart geht einfach auf große Länge und nachdem es geöffnet wurde, nachdem wir gesehen haben, was es war, sind wir einfach nicht zurückgegangen.
Entschuldigung, Mann, es ist, was es ist, aber wir sind keine Fans überhaupt. Nun gehen wir weiter zu Nummer vier, wir haben
Submersed. Dies ist ein Survival-Horror-Spiel, in dem du ein emergency paramedic bist, dessen Schwester
stirbt und dann geht er zurück zur Arbeit, aber er endet mit einem crash landing auf dieser verlassenen Struktur
im Mittelpunkt des Ozeans und schau dir das an, es ist teils submersiert und einer der Hauptenemien sind
Scharke, was ein wirklich großartiges Konzept ist, aber es ist einfach unglaublich unerwartet, weil ich noch nie etwas davon gehört habe, ich dachte mir gar nichts.
Das größte Problem, das mit dem Spiel zu haben, ist, dass es einfach unerwartet und präsent ist und wirklich
einfach mit minimalen Überraschungen. Und ehrlich gesagt, manchmal ist das der größte Schmerz aller Dinge,
du weißt, der einzigartigste Element, das Scharke-Spiel, war nicht so großartig, wie es sein könnte. Es ist einfach ein schlechtes
Survival-Horror-Spiel, du weißt, es ist so steif, aber es fühlt sich ein bisschen halbartig an, es gibt ein
Inventar-Management-System, aber es ist auch anscheinend auch nicht schlimm.
Wenn ich
das Menü schon sehe, Leute, wenn ich solche, das sind Menüs, das sind Menüs, die man mal während der
Entwicklung macht, damit man selbst ein Menü hat und das Menü ausprobieren kann. Aber das sind doch
keine Menüs, die man in ein fertiges Game packt. Man kann ziemlich gut, finde ich jetzt, man kann ziemlich gut
anhand von Ingame-Menüs erkennen, welchen Polish und wie viel Mühegebstatus ein Game hat. Und das hier
hat, hat keinen.
Alex, Switch Prime, danke schön.
Pfeifhead, sub.
Big Prime, sub.
Prime, sub ist
sub ist
Die zeigen überhaupt kein Rumgeklitsche.
Es ist übelst kaputt, ey.
Also schön sieht es nicht aus.
Guckt euch mal den Tisch an.
Und die Pflanze da hinten, Alter.
Und den Raum allgemein.
Und vor allem.
Warum hat der Dude da irgendwie ein Tablet hängen?
Was macht das da?
Billion Dollar Company.
The PC version is prone to tons of freezing
and like weird crashes
and just tons of graphical glitches abound
whatever console you're playing on, honestly.
And every year, you know, it's started to feel more and more
like the little updates here and there.
So wie ich das in Videos gesehen habe,
glitscht man da auch ganz gerne mal durch den Boden und sowas.
Und vor allem, was richtig abgedreht aussieht,
ist, wenn sie in den Seilen hängen bleiben.
WWE 2K20, a downright bummer.
I really think they need to go back to the drawing board
with these games, big time.
Now, down to number two.
Speaking of going back to the drawing board,
we have Anthem, a game that you're probably gonna see
on a lot of top 10 worst games of 2019.
Ja, das war auch in unserer Top 10 worst Liste drin.
It's kind of obvious, like at this point,
like I feel like we're beating a dead horse,
we're kicking a game while it's down.
But Anthem was a collection of like the worst elements
of a games as a service game.
It was rushed out the door,
Bioware clearly did a good job.
Der eine, du weißt schon, moin.
Das war verkackt, Anthem, Alter.
Worlds felt empty,
enemy types,
weren't really that exciting.
The raid wasn't in place.
The roadmap, after all,
the backlash has been completely
kind of scrapped and rethought.
Bioware has been scrambling
to make this a much better game.
But the problem is,
that it came out of the oven
just drastically undercooked.
Die wussten ja während der Entwicklung
nicht, was es werden soll.
Und genauso fühlt sich das an.
But ultimately,
the game does not put the work in
to get you to really enjoy it.
You know, the loot isn't that satisfying.
The story isn't that satisfying.
Say what you will about games like
Destiny or Warfare,
you might not like them
because they're games as a service game,
but they have fanbases for reasons.
Because the people behind the games
really put the work in
to make a fun, compelling game first
that'll keep you playing.
Anthem was just a hot mess.
Not only just because of the game
Das ist das, was ich,
das sag ich ja auch immer
bei dieser ganzen Service-Game-Thematik.
Damit man das überhaupt
in Erwägung ziehen kann,
muss das Base-Game richtig gut sein.
Hätte man zum Beispiel Battlefield 3 genommen
und gesagt, hey,
man strickt darum jetzt in drei Jahren,
dass man ein anderes Content-Plan
und will dafür öfters auch mal Kohle haben
oder irgendwelchen Abo-Pass
oder irgendwas und so.
Vollkommen okay,
weil das Base-Game gut war.
Aber was halt immer scheiße ist,
wenn das Base-Game suckt
und du es danach halbwegs gut machst,
da sind die Leute schon längst weggerannt.
Dass das bei Rainbow Six
so gut geklappt hat,
grenzt an ein Wunder für mich schon irgendwie,
weil das war am Anfang auch nicht so geil.
Dann sind viele Leute wieder abgesprungen.
Aber dadurch,
dass sie das relativ schnell in den Griff gekriegt haben
und jetzt auch relativ lange,
sind halt viele Leute wieder hingekommen,
weil sie halt gesehen haben,
okay, die haben das Vertrauen zurückgewonnen da drin.
Aber bei sowas ist halt komplett für den Arsch.
Die sind halt weg.
Die könnten da jetzt
den besten Patch aller Zeiten raushauen
mit ihren fünf Spielern oder so,
die sie noch haben.
Juckt das halt keinen mehr.
Dafür wusste Destiny von Anfang an,
was das machen will.
Auch wenn der Endgame-Content bei Destiny halt auch, naja.
Aber wir hoffen wirklich, dass sie es in 2020 umdrehen können.
Aber trotzdem,
gehen wir weiter zu Nummer 1.
Und sprechen wir über Left Alive.
Dieses Spiel war für uns ein massiver Letdown,
weil die Schreibung auf dem Ball ist ziemlich spannend.
Es ist ein neues Spiel,
das in der Front-Mission-Universum gesetzt wird.
Es ist wie ein Spinoff, ein neues Abenteuer.
Viele der originalen Front-Mission-Mitglieder waren dahinter
und hatten einiges von japanischem Gewicht.
Es gab auch Yoji Shinkawa als Charakter- und Konzeptarzt,
der hinter sich lag.
Na dann.
Ja, das war das, was da total abgekackt hat.
Das haben wir letztens schon mal gesehen.
Guck mal, wie es die Gegner nicht checken.
Krasser AI.
Diese Animationen sehen doch übelst freudig aus.
Und diese Lauf-Animationen, ey.
Ja, das sieht aus wie ein 360-Game,
was am Anfang der Generation rausgekommen ist.
Ja, das sieht aus wie ein 360-Game, was am Anfang der Generation rausgekommen ist.
Es hat nach wie vor sehr gute Effekte und eine gute Musik-Score.
Es ist einfach nicht aufgefallen, wenn sie es ausprobiert haben.
Keiner von denen war aufregend.
Was bei den Getriebe情 bildet, war umfangreich.
An den Krawодарiechen und allem anderen
war es einfach unzögreich.
Wie das Spiel so um so viel Stealth konzentriert wurde.
Es wurde erstens als Stealth-Game hergestellt.
Wie?
Was ist los?
Dieses Spiel ist Nummer eins, weil es nicht so gut ist.
Nummer eins.
Und weil es übrigens ein großer Lauf-Animation war.
Verlierungen und Verlust waren wirklich das große Thema auf dieser Liste.
Aber ich habe das gar nicht so sehr verfolgt, aber das taucht in ganz vielen Listen auf.
Und es scheint was dran zu sein.
Okay, und jetzt gucken wir den Worst Console Launch Google Stadia.
Mal gucken.
Also es hat gemischte Bewertungen.
Gucken, ob der einfach nur rumflamed oder auch was.
Also das ist die Stadia Werbung.
Ob der auch was sagen kann.
Uncharted 1 sah besser aus.
Generell sah Uncharted extrem gut aus.
Hast du deine Stadia jetzt?
Ich habe die abbestellt.
Negativ Latency, sage ich nur.
Oh ne, ist das so ein YouTube Mensch, der rumschreit?
Dann mache ich das gleich wieder aus.
I've personally witnessed the rise of titans, consoles that started from nothing and rose to fame and legend, but I've also seen the failures.
It all begins on launch day, a consoles birth into the world.
That is its introduction to gamers, but it also is the most important day in a consoles life.
Companies plan this one single day for months, even years.
Ja, das ist so.
So many moving pieces have to fall into place just so for the launch to go successfully.
Das Video ist gut, okay, da gucken wir das.
Wenn der Chat das sagt.
It could mean years.
Years of profit and fame.
But what if the pieces don't fall into place?
Well, folks, as far as I can see, we just witnessed what I would consider to be the worst video game platform launch of all time.
And today, my friends, we're going to be exploring that very launch.
Der schreit gleich richtig laut, ich hoffe nicht, ja.
It's time to talk about the Google Stadia.
Der ist schon so richtig, das ist so ein typischer YouTube Mensch einfach.
So von der ganzen Art.
Wie da geredet wird, äh.
A word of warning.
Some of you might not think it's fair to compare Stadia against traditional video game console boxes.
Na klar, na klar ist das fair.
Na klar ist das fair.
Die, die, die werben ja selbst damit, dass sie die bessere Alternative sind und vor allem, dass sie quasi enttäuscht werden, wenn sie nur so viele Spiele hätten wie eine PS4 und sowas in der Richtung.
Ne, also da, natürlich kann man das vergleichen.
Muss man sogar.
Unfortunately, though, the folks at Google do not agree with you.
In fact, they even encourage it.
Stadia is not constrained by the limitation of traditional console systems.
Instead of a console or a PC, you're using Google's data center as the platform.
10.7 teraflops is more powerful than the top two consoles of the previous generation.
Ja, da haben sie sich auch wieder was zurechtgerechnet, äh.
So, we've got to hold them to the standards that were set by current industry icons like Nintendo, Sony and Microsoft.
What did they announce?
Wherever you are, Stadia lets you play the latest games.
The idea is...
The idea of a box sat beside your TV was gone.
Now you'd be streaming through the power of the Internet.
Games would be streamed directly to your video signal at 4K, 60 frames per second,
while a big, powerful Stadia computer somewhere far away did all the hard work.
At launch later this year, you'll be able to play Stadia games on your TV, desktop, laptop, tablet...
Ja, wenn's dann funktionieren würde.
Are they getting this, folks?
No expensive console was necessary.
All you needed was a capable device like a phone, laptop, tablet or whatever you had with a screen that could get this to work,
and you'd be playing games faster than ever before.
Wherever you are, Stadia lets you play the latest games.
But then we got to see the controller.
Controllers can be different and exciting.
The form factor alone can define the identity of a console,
like the GameCube controller, the PlayStation DualShock, and so many more.
They could also demonstrate new features that could be combined with games.
New features that could become unique to their new platform.
Like the reveal of the Nintendo Wii's motion controls,
they could show something revolutionary to help make the platform stand out.
It's just a regular looking controller, with really no new features at all, huh?
Well, that's lame.
And if power was what you were looking for, they showed off the specs,
proclaiming it to be faster than all current consoles.
Which, I'd hope your brand new platform is actually faster than a quarter decade old console.
Or a joke, not much of a surprise.
Yeah, that's true.
Especially since the comparison is such a fail,
to something that's under your desk,
and to something that's in a rack, in a computer center.
So, the comparison was really bad back then.
...is there, but how does it actually play?
Will you see this dude right here?
Well, he demoed it, showing how easy and fast it was to switch between displays.
How well did it work?
Well, the screens turned on, that much we could guarantee.
But if you looked at his hands really closely,
while he was playing, you could tell that the inputs
were being heavily delayed in certain instances.
Boy, you'd really think they'd wanna hide that.
And I think they sort of did.
We didn't see any...
Moment, von wann ist denn das Video? Ist das...
Ja, doch, ist aktuell.
...long gameplay on stage, and everything was just pretty much very short.
Leading me to believe that maybe this system wasn't working as well as they hoped.
Regardless though, the promise in...
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen X6, Nachrichten, X64,
wie viel irgendein Register reinpasst?
...is that you'll be able to play Stadia on anything, anywhere you want.
Wherever you are, Stadia lets you play the latest games.
It would be fast, it would work, and there would be no headaches.
We would hope.
People, including myself, walked away from that whole GDC announcement,
incorrectly believing that Stadia would be a platform like Netflix,
pay a set amount of money per month,
and have access to a whole bunch of content.
And it would make sense too, because their service looked like...
Das... das... das... das... konnte man am Anfang denken,
aber war eigentlich relativ schnell klar, dass es eher nicht so wird.
...the next step from something like PlayStation Now,
a game streaming service on PlayStation 4.
Pay one monthly fee and stream any game from the curated library.
That selection combined with Stadia's implied power and flexibility
seemed like it would be a pretty good deal.
Well, that's not how it...
Alter, reg dich ab!
...after a long bout of silence,
Google would dump a bunch of information about Stadia. YouTube 2019.
...including that in order to play Stadia on day one,
you'd need what they called the Founder's Edition.
For 129 big ones, you would get a limited edition Stadia controller,
a Chromecast Ultra, which you'd need to play on a TV,
and a free...
Und ich hab's abbestellt, nicht weil ich denke,
also ich bin ja eh der Meinung, dass wir failen
und demnächst auf dem Google-Friedhof landen,
aber ich hab es abbestellt, weil ich, glaube ich,
zwei Monate oder so vorher
eine Founder's Edition geordert habe
und die wollten mir ernsthaft erzählen,
das Ding kommt einen Monat ungefähr,
ich hab's ja auf Twitter gepostet,
irgendwie einen Monat, drei Wochen oder so,
ich weiß nicht mal, wie lang es genau war,
nach Release.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, alter,
wenn ich den Scheiß zweieinhalb Monate vorher bestellt hab,
oder drei Monate vorher bestellt hab,
und ich bekomm es drei Wochen oder so nach Release,
was ist denn das für ein Crap?
Und da hab ich's abbestellt.
Das seh ich nicht ein, ganz ehrlich.
Warum machen sie sowas überhaupt zum Vorbestellen,
wenn du es da nicht kriegst?
Das ist total hängen geblieben, einfach nur.
...Subscription to Stadia Pro.
So that means...
Und ich bestell selten Sachen ab.
...anything service at launch actually has a cost to it
that requires you to have purchased physical hardware.
So that makes this cloud-based, non-hardware-reliant service
actually a hardware-based console release.
Imagine that.
Wherever you are, Stadia lets you play the latest games.
But back to what you get in that bundle.
What is Stadia Pro?
You might think it's a monthly price
to get a whole library of games to play, right?
Well, it's not.
Stadia Pro is basically a monthly cost that is added on top
that gives you a few free games every so often
and grants you the ability to play Stadia in full quality.
That's right, folks.
Stadia can only be experienced
if you promise 4K at 60 frames per second
when you pay an additional fee upfront each month.
Well, that's a terrible ice cream sundae.
But you want a cherry on top?
Die PS4 kostet nicht monatlich.
Die PS4 kostet nur monatlich, wenn du online spielen willst.
Wenn du einfach nur Singleplayer-Spiele spielen willst,
was ganz viele Leute machen wollen,
musst du bei der PS4 nichts bezahlen.
You still have to pay full price for games
just like traditional old school video game consoles.
That means if you buy a game
and don't pay that extra cash per month,
you won't actually be experiencing the game
in the best way possible.
By eliminating that friction, that barrier to entry,
we will make it simple and easy
for players who want to try Stadia for the first time.
Sweet deal!
So, to sum up what has happened...
Naja, die ursprüngliche Idee war,
dass du keine Hardware von Google dafür brauchst,
um es benutzen zu können,
sondern dass du einfach deinen normalen Rechner nimmst,
Browser aufmachst und spielen kannst.
So war das gedacht.
Aktuell, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch so ist,
sie wollen ja davon weg, also es soll ja geöffnet werden,
aktuell brauchst du das offizielle Bundle mit dem Chromecast drin.
Du kannst das nicht einfach auf deinem Desktop spielen.
Das wollen sie machen, ja,
aber so wie es aktuell ist,
stelle ich mir da unter so einer Cloud-Gaming-Lösung
schon ein bisschen was anderes vor.
So far, the announcement was confusing.
Nobody really knew what to expect.
Das geht doch eigentlich, es soll gehen.
Aber beim Release ging es nicht.
It got seemingly more confusing.
Beim Release musstest du das mit dem Chromecast spielen.
Oder ich glaube, ein Chromebook ging auch.
Diesen Chromecast oder einen Chromebook.
Ich glaube, ein Chromebook ging irgendwie auch.
Oder, ich glaube, es ging drei Sachen.
Irgendwie ein Chromebook, ein aktuelles Handy von Google
oder Chromecast.
Ich glaube, diese drei Sachen gingen am Anfang.
Du konntest nicht einfach mit dem Browser hin.
Stadia...
Gucken wir doch mal, gucken wir doch mal.
Ja, aktuell nur Support für Pixel.
Ich sage, du brauchst ein aktuelles Google-Handy.
Premiere Edition.
Genau, du brauchst diesen Chromecast,
wenn du es auf dem Fernseher spielen willst.
Mit Google Chromecast Ultra 4K.
Genau.
Twitch-Zuschauer, ganz genau.
Das muss, das muss Hardware-unabhängig sein.
Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Lösung?
So, und jetzt können wir mal gucken.
Was soll ich oben gucken?
Smartphones?
Ja, guck, genau.
Ne.
Du brauchst einen Chromecast.
Ja, was, wo soll ich gucken?
Bis zu 60 FPS.
Ja, Porgas.
Was, über Kaufen?
Wenn du es kaufen willst, musst du dir einen Chromecast kaufen.
Das geht aktuell.
Es soll mal in Zukunft gehen.
Stadia Chrome Windows.
Play Stadia on Chrome.
Okay.
Geht das schon?
Das probieren wir, das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Play Stadia on Chrome.
You can play Stadia on the web with latest Chrome.
Wäre cool, wenn das jetzt schon funktioniert.
Am Anfang musstest du das mit diesem, du konntest das am Anfang, konntest du das auf einem Chromebook machen, auf einem Handy und, und, äh, mit diesem komischen Chromecast.
Buy now.
Ne, die wollen unbedingt, dass ich diesen Kram kaufe.
Wie kann ich das mit Chrome spielen?
Launch Stadia on Web by visiting using Google Chrome.
Sign up.
Sign in.
Ah.
Weißt du, du musst dich per Handy-App.
Genau.
Und du, und, und per Handy-App, das, das, das ging aber dann auch übers iPhone, ne?
Das habe ich gelesen.
Du konntest, die iPhone-Stadia-App kann aktuell nur sign in, sonst nix.
Play Stadia Chrome Windows.
Here is a rundown how to play Stadia on PC.
Okay.
Requires Google Chrome.
Das ist ja klar.
Da habe ich jetzt auch nicht anders mit gerechnet.
Controls by default.
Ja, warum, warum sollte ich denn überhaupt diese komische Hardware kaufen?
On TV.
Ach, das war's.
Okay.
Man kann es auf dem PC spielen, aber die höchste Einstellung geht nur auf, nur mit dem Chromecast.
Was auch irgendwie sehr merkwürdig ist, ne?
Until, ach, das war das, genau.
Du kannst auf dem PC erst irgendwann 2020 eventuell mal.
Trotzdem, hey.
Pott, du bist doch auf den Arsch.
Es ist halt wirklich 10 von 10, wenn man Google muss, wenn man Stadia spielen kann.
Ja.
Leider sind viele Google-Services so.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal die Google, die Google-Account-Settings an, ey.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist eine gute Frage, die ich mir gerade gesehen habe.
Das ist wirklich zu witzig.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das so ist.
Ich bin ja auch ein bisschen für den Albinoplex-Sheep.
Er sagt, wha, ich bin gerade durch Zufall auf den Stream gestoßen und würde auch gerne
mal meinen Senf dazu abgeben.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum auf Stadia so rumgehackt wird.
Es ist halt neue Technik und muss erst mal optimiert werden.
Früher gab es ja auch keine Autos mit 500 PS.
Genau so sehe ich das auch hier.
Dass man an einem Fernseher spielen kann, braucht man eben noch so ein Chromecast.
Finde ich überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Am besten, dass man sich dann auch noch so ein bisschen mit dem PC befindet.
GPS, genau so sehe ich das auch hier, dass man an einem Fernsehspielen kann, braucht man eben noch so ein Chromecast, finde ich überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Am PC braucht man doch einfach nur Google Chrome. Wo ist das Problem?
Das Problem ist, was ich da aktuell dran sehe, erstens, es ist keine neue Technik in dem Sinn.
Das gibt es seit 10 Jahren schon.
Den riesen Vorteil, den Google hat, ist, dass die halt die Infrastruktur drumherum haben, das Ganze machen zu können.
Und, ähm, was war das andere? Ich bin...
Achso, warum auf Stadien so rumgehackt wird, beziehungsweise neue Techniken optimiert werden.
Naja, Google hat halt selbst auf richtig dicke Hose gemacht.
So nach dem Motto, Negativ Latency, ähm, dass es quasi besser ist als die anderen Plattformen.
Die vergleichen sich ja direkt mit anderen Plattformen.
Dann erzählen sie so Sachen wie, dass sie quasi fast schon enttäuscht wären, wenn sie nur so wenige Spieler wie auf der Playstation hätten.
Und sowas in der Richtung.
Also, im Prinzip, die wollen ja, die wollen ja gemessen werden an dem, was bei anderen schon geht.
Sie sind da selbst dran schuld, ja.
Hätten die ein bisschen kleinere Brötchen gebacken, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich auch nicht so...
Würden sich nicht so viele darüber beschweren.
Aber, ich mein, man kann sich ja über das beschweren, was sie angepriesen haben und was halt nicht so ist.
Nö, dass man nur 60 FPS hat, ist nicht schlimm.
60 FPS für die normalen... Das ist kein Ding für die meisten Dinger.
Aber ich sag's, ich hab's ja ganz am Anfang schon gesagt...
Wenn, äh, als sie das damals, das allererste Google-Stadia-Zeug, was sie angekündigt haben.
Ich hab gesagt, ich kauf denen ihr ganze Latency-Versprechen erst ab, ähm, sobald ein CS-Team den Major auf Stadia gewinnt.
Dann kauf ich ihnen ihre Latency-Versprechen ab.
Und Leute, soll ich euch mal spoilern, das werden wir wahrscheinlich nie sehen.
Die haben ja am Anfang so, so riesen, riesen Versprechungen gemacht.
Ich mein, negativ, allein schon, wie hirnverbrannt diese Versprechung gewesen ist.
Negativ-Latency.
Also, ich mein, hat Google jetzt irgendwie ne neue Physik erfunden oder, oder haben die irgendwie festgestellt, dass es doch schneller geht als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit?
Was sie damit gemeint haben, was sie damit gemeint...
Also, ne, Schwachsinn, was sie damit gemeint...
Sie haben schon das genau damit gemeint.
Sie wollten es auch so dastehen lassen.
Ähm, von der Logik her sagen sie, ja, okay, negativ-Latency heißt ja quasi, wenn alle jetzt bei Stadia zusammen Multiplayer spielen,
dann ist die Verbindung innerhalb von Stadia schneller.
Ja?
Weil die Leute müssen ja nicht mehr von zu Hause übers Internet zu nem Server und vom Server zu den Mitspielern, sondern sind direkt in Stadia drinnen.
Das Problem bei der Sache ist nur,
der, die wichtigste, die mit Abstand wichtigste Latency, die es in nem Game gibt,
ist...
Action, also...
Aktion, Reaktion.
Du musst, so schnell wie möglich, wenn du was drückst, wenn du was machst, musst du das Feedback sehen.
Und das ist das, wo halt Stadia...
Nichts davon hat, wenn die anderen Mitspieler neben dir auf dem gleichen Server laufen.
Das mag dann im Endeffekt, wenn, wenn deine Daten da hingeschickt worden sind und so, und quasi Multiplayer-Kommunikation mag das sein,
aber das ist nicht so das Problem.
Ich mein, guck mal, ich hab zu nem Battlefield-Server in Köln, hab ich 8 Millisekunden Latency, als würd's das jetzt fett machen.
Wichtig ist, dass ich, äh, ordentlich...
Und, das sind ein paar Kilobyte, die ich da hinübertragen muss, ja?
Also es ist deutlich einfacher, meine Spiele-Daten zu nem Battlefield-Server...
und zurück zu übertragen, als nen kompletten, äh, 4K, 60 FPS Video-Stream mit, weiß was ich, 15 Mbit oder 20 Mbit, was das Ding hat, ich weiß nicht.
Ähm, die paar Kilobyte-Daten zum Battlefield-Server.
Also es ist viel, viel einfacher, das responsive zu machen, wenn's bei mir aufm Rechner läuft.
Und wie gesagt, je ganzes negative Latency und sonst was, äh, gelabert, das hab ich von Anfang an gesagt,
ich glaub, dass den erst, wenn ein CS-Team nen Major gewinnt, auf Stadia, was halt nicht passieren wird.
Das, genau das Gefühl, genau das Gefühl hab ich auch, Plutonern.
Hehehe.
Ein BWLer bei Google dachte sich, lass uns auch Gaming machen.
Genau so fühlt sich für mich Stadia an.
Exakt so, hast du gut beschrieben.
Ich mein, hätten die jetzt, so wie das Royal Maroc sagt, hätten die jetzt gesagt, okay, bei, ähm, warte mal, ähm, hätten die jetzt gesagt,
hey, bei nem Google-Stadia-Paket ist noch Google-Fiber dabei, hehehe, und wir legen euch das Kabel.
Ja gut, dann hätt ich, dann hätt ich das ja geglaubt, dass das technisch besser geht.
Was natürlich infrastrukturmäßig nicht umsetzbar gewesen wär.
Dann wär's zumindest technisch irgendwie drinne gewesen.
Und, äh, eins muss man auch sagen, es ist auch keine, keine neue Technik, man kann das selbst machen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich euch das mal gezeigt hab.
Ähm, das hab ich mit dem Fabian ein paarmal verwendet, um Spiele zusammenzuspielen.
Das ist richtig gut.
Ähm, du kannst quasi auf deinem eigenen Windows-Server ne, ne, ne, ne, ne Parsec-Server hosten.
Ist das das überhaupt?
Ja, ich glaub, das ist das.
Genau.
Äh, du kannst...
Du kannst da, du kannst ne eigene, ne eigene Sache hosten.
Und, äh, das ist tatsächlich relativ latency-free, wenn du nen ordentlichen, ordentlichen Internetanschluss hast.
Kann man?
Ham...
You cannot host on a Windows...
Kann man hosten on Linux?
Das muss ich unbedingt ausprobieren, ob man auf Linux hosten kann.
Da wär ich...
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Muss ich mir mal nachher angucken.
Also, das geht ja anderweitig auch.
Und der erste Service war, glaub ich, onLive vor, vor 10 Jahren oder so.
Ist jetzt ewig her.
Ähm, die das auch schon gemacht haben.
Die hatten natürlich nicht die, die hatten natürlich nicht die Infrastruktur von Google, das ist klar.
Das ist, das ist eigentlich der einzige Riesenvorteil, den Google bei Stadia hat, ist ihre Infrastruktur.
Also sprich, ihre, ihre Netzwerkinfrastruktur weltweit, ihre Rechenzentren weltweit und generell halt einfach ihre Hardware-Power weltweit.
Das ist der Riesenvorteil, den Google bei Stadia hat.
Ansonsten können die, äh, können die halt auch nicht zaubern.
Merkt man bei Stadia eigentlich die Latenz im Spielen?
Ich würde sagen, das kommt auf die Spiele an.
Sag mal, wenn man so Third-Person-Spiele wie Assassin's Creed hat oder so und der Server relativ nah dran ist, ähm, ist das, ist das, denke ich, vielleicht merkt man es, aber es ist nicht so gut spielbar.
Wirst du wirklich, wirst du was, was anspruchsvolles, schnelles, Competitive-Multiplayer spielen?
Auf jeden Fall.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Wo war man?
Es gibt, man muss halt sagen, es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, ne?
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, das habe ich schon, schön, dass er Pause gemacht hat.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass man das über den Chromecast spielen muss.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ein aktueller PC zu schlecht wäre, den 4K-Stream abzuspielen.
Es ist ja im Endeffekt der Riesenvorteil.
Davon auch, du musst nichts mehr selbst berechnen, du musst einen 4K-Stream abspielen.
Das kann, das kann ein Fire TV.
Wird den Typen ja schon sehr anstrengend, ja, gebe ich dir recht.
Das ist so typische, typischer YouTube-Mensch halt.
Wobei, ja, der Witz ist, dass auf dem iPhone kann man sich, glaube ich, die App nur verwenden, um sich einzuloggen.
Ich glaube, also zumindest bei dem letzten Review, was ich gesehen habe, war das so, dass du die iPhone-App von Stadia zu nichts anderem verwenden kannst, als sich einzuloggen.
Was natürlich auch irgendwie ein bisschen Fail ist, wozu gibt es da eine App?
Quatsch da, drei Monate, Twitch Prime, Big Prime Sub, Dankeschön.
Prime, Samus Prime.
Have a Pixel, Stadia doesn't work.
Ja, die meisten YouTube-Menschen sind halt anstrengend.
Kind of getting limited here, aren't we?
Wherever you are, Stadia lets you play the latest games.
So, through all of that mixed information flying around, there was doubt and uncertainty.
Google hat halt einfach zu, zu übertrieben.
I found myself paying for a founder's pack.
I'm a founder.
Now, folks, I was on the fence for a while, but when a friend of mine wanted out from the upcoming train wreck, I happily bought his ticket and got his pre-order.
So, I hopped on for a ride, and that leads us...
...to the day of launch.
November 19th, 2019.
Launch day.
So, what happened?
Well, the launch day for many came and passed without their...
Ja, ja, und das, und das war der Punkt, wo ich mein Stadia abgestellt hab.
...Founder's Edition's arriving.
Yup, that's usually not how these things go, but hey, no worries, we should still be able to turn on Stadia and play it.
Ich mein, warum heißt das Ding Founder's Edition und du kannst es vorbestellen?
Because it's in the cloud.
You don't need all that funny hardware that they were mailing you, right?
Well, no.
There was another problem that existed.
And that problem was called the Stadia Launch Codes.
Now, what could those be?
Well, they're literal codes that Google would send you via email to activate and start your account.
These didn't go out to everyone at the same time, and in some cases, they arrived days later.
And by the way, even if you got your Founder's Edition in the mail, but you didn't get the activation codes,
couldn't actually play Google Stadia.
Wild.
As for myself, I was lucky.
I got the code in the dead of night after the morning launch, spending my whole day waiting.
As for the hardware, I got that a full day later.
November 20th, 2019.
The day after launch day.
It's almost unheard of to miss your launch day in the big leagues of the console world.
But missed it they did.
Finally, after all this waiting, what was Stadia like?
How did the platform play?
Well, folks, this is where it gets really funny.
I've personally experienced every possible problem you could have in a video game streaming service.
Input lag measured into full-on seconds, making almost any game on the platform virtually uncontrollable.
But don't take my word for it.
Wahrscheinlich wohnt er einfach nur schlecht.
Und er müsste einfach umziehen.
Da wohnt einfach nur schlecht.
Haben wir doch gestern im Vortrag gelernt.
Where is Gene Park from the Washington Post at their head offices demonstrating the input lag?
Woo-wee, that's some instant action if you ask me.
Wobei das auch nur die halbe Wahrheit ist.
Der gleiche Typ hat, glaube ich, einen Tag später, ähm, einen Tag später hat der noch ein Video gemacht.
Hat gesagt, jetzt läuft's deutlich besser.
... demonstrating the input lag.
Woo-wee, that's some instant action if you ask me.
In Wirklichkeit, genau, sneaky boy, du hast recht, in Wirklichkeit ist das hier der negative Input Lag.
In Wirklichkeit ist das nämlich nicht der Knopfdruck, der von ihm da angezeigt wird, sondern schon der übernächste Knopfdruck, der ihm angezeigt wird, bevor er den Knopf gedrückt hat.
Das ist es, Leute.
Revealed.
Es funktioniert alles, wir sind bloß zu blöd, es zu kapieren.
Woo-wee, that's some instant action if you ask me.
Eleven hat, äh...
Stadia ist eine Infrastruktur, die niemand anderes hat.
Mehrere Edge-Nodes bedeuten, dass die Computer-Resourcen näher zu den Spielern sind, was eine bessere Leistung erzeugt.
Wenn der Input-Lag dich nicht gekriegt hat, vielleicht würden die randomen Framedrops auch.
Es passiert plötzlich und überall.
Du weißt nie, wann es aufwächst.
Aber wenn es kommt, ist es schrecklich.
...
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Das ist halt, wenn der Stream...
Das ist halt so, wenn du einen Stream hast, ne?
Wenn du einen Stream hast und nicht genug Frames kriegst.
Also Diffs.
Ja, wenn du sogar eine Keyframe verpasst, ist besonders bitter.
...
I don't care what excuses anyone makes for this, but they don't work on me.
I've played every major video game console that has ever been released,
including rare and obscure hardware that failed to grab traction.
Nothing I've ever played that was new had issues like this.
It's unheard of.
And the big problem with that...
...is that you'll likely find at least a few people online who have not had any problems,
because maybe they've got the right connection.
Maybe they're closer to the Stadia servers.
Maybe they just have the same...
Nein, mit einer 2K-Leitung kannst du es komplett vergessen.
Das ist auch eines der größten Probleme, die wir mit Diensten wie Stadia in Deutschland haben.
Das ist der Hintergrund.
...right mix of everything to work.
Who knows?
But not being able to guarantee that it will work for everyone, every single time?
Inexcusable!
Think I'm being unfair?
Well, how about this as an example?
If you bought a brand new Nintendo Switch and it only played games sometimes,
and the other times it just didn't turn on,
wouldn't you return it?
Yeah, I thought so.
Wherever you are, Stadia lets you play the latest...
Ey, es hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Was?
muss man mal sagen
also ist schon
es hat schon gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
muss man mal sagen
wer hätte das gedacht bei einem Google Projekt
dass es nicht so gut funktioniert wie angepriesen
da hätte man überhaupt nicht drauf kommen können
das kann nicht sein
ich weiß gar nicht was dieser
dieser Vergleich ist so
so aus der Lüge
mit was vergleichen die das denn
bitteschön überhaupt
das habe ich mich schon gefragt
was ist das für ein Vergleich
hier hast du eine Box
unterm Schreibtisch stehen
da ist halt das an Hardware drin
da hast du eine Box unterm Schreibtisch stehen
hier hast du gar keine Box unterm Schreibtisch stehen
und irgendwie in diesem Rechenzentrum
läuft dein Spiel
also was ist das für ein Vergleich
das ist einfach besser als die aktuellen Top-Systeme
und mein PC sollte nicht sogar ein Konter sein
weil, sagen wir mal, Super Computer Blade
gegen eine Box in meinem Wohnzimmer
Super Computer sollte gewinnen
aber es wird nicht
anstatt einer Konsole oder einem PC
benutzt du Google's Datacenter als Plattform
Stadia reist meistens Spiele mit niedrigeren Resolutionen
als ich davon gelesen wurde
das war etwas was ich sofort bemerkt habe
als ich angefangen habe zu spielen
Spiele sahen einfach nicht so gut aus
wie man sie sehen kann
das sind die kleinen Spiele, die man hier auf der Szene sieht
wenn ich so spiele
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es gar nicht mal so sehr daran liegt
dass die wirklich
also vielleicht in niedrigeren Auslösungen liegen
aber die Spiele sind ja extra angepasst für Stadia
und je nachdem
wie sie das gemacht haben
unterscheiden sich die Spiele im Output halt ein bisschen
aber klar, ich meine auf dem PC lokal ist es schon eindeutig schärfer
dazu kommen auch Kompressionen vom Stream
Xbox One X oder mein PC
aber das ist schon ein Riesenunterschied
da guckt euch das mal an
siehst sofort
und das ist eine Unterschiede, die ich in mehreren Spielen bemerken kann
mit mehreren Beispielen
jetzt, warum ist das ein Problem?
na gut, Phil Harrison auf Twitter
einen Monat vor dem Launch von Stadia
sagte, dass alle Spiele am Launch
4K unterstützen würden
wo auch immer du bist, lässt Stadia dir die neuesten Spiele spielen
aber weißt du was?
ich denke, was er bedeutet ist, dass der Videostream
bei 4K läuft
das bedeutet nicht, dass das ein Spiel ist
was du also bekommst, ist ein niedrigeres Spiel
das ist halt typische BWL Big Brain Logik
seit wann supportet der Chrome 4K?
nein, du brauchst ja ein extra Gerät um in 4k zu spielen
Erstmal schön upscalen.
Naja, man muss ja sagen, wenn eine Sache einfach ist bei Stadia, dann ist es Hardware Upgrade.
Das ist wirklich easy.
Ich meine, die müssen einfach nur ihre Hardware austauschen und schon sehen die Games besser auf und laufen besser.
Ich muss mir eine neue Konsole holen, dass das gleiche der Fall ist.
Gerade deswegen ist auch dieser Vergleich, den sie da in ihrer Präsentation hatten, total beknackt.
Die Stadia Bibliothek ist nicht gut.
Das ist es, was Stadia alles umfasst. Die Games.
Ich denke, es ist ziemlich offensichtlich zu sehen, dass dieses ganze Event eine massive Serie von Problemen war,
die sich auf das, was nur mit dem Laufen zu tun hat, gebildet hat, als die Verletzung eines Launches.
Selbst wenn die vielen Spieler da draußen, die frische Stadia-Wunde haben,
es gibt viele andere, die nichts mehr hatten als Sonne und Räume.
Und es wird wahrscheinlich ein core-Grupp von Leuten sein, die von Stadia aufstehen,
die es als beste Option für ein ganzes paar Videogames spielen, und das ist in Ordnung.
Stadia basiert auf deiner Internet-Konnexion, die konsistent, solide und schnell genug ist, um ständig zu arbeiten.
Es gibt nur eine priviligierte Sicht, die so eine Stabilität beurteilen kann.
Und auch mit all den Internet-Konnexionen, die ich besitzen kann, ist das noch nicht eine Realität für mich.
Wenn du Stadia als Lichtschalter denkst, und wenn du es anmachst, es hat nicht immer die Lichter an,
dann würdest du es nicht vertrauen, oder?
Und ich denke, das ist es, was Stadia ist.
Ein Lichtschalter, den du nicht vertrauen kannst.
Ich kann dir keine Antwort geben auf den langfristigen Erfolg von Stadia.
Stadia schlägt eine Bravour.
Wird es einen neuen Weg in die Geschichte der Spiele gehen, oder wird es in die Richtung des Cloud-Gaming-Services von OnLive gehen?
Was ist OnLive, fragst du?
Genau mein Punkt.
Aber was auch immer das Resultat ist, was auch immer die Zukunft hält, was auch immer es passieren könnte,
wenn ich an Stadia denke, denke ich immer an eine Sache.
Es hat den schlechtesten Konsole-Launch jemals.
Und zwar, das bewegt sich eindeutig in diese Richtung und wird sich vielleicht nicht nächstes Jahr,
vielleicht nicht übernächstes Jahr, aber wenn das so weitergeht, auf absehbare Zeit,
wird sich Stadia auf dem Google-Friedhof wiederfinden.
Und vielleicht haben wir ja Glück und zumindest der Chromecast Ultra wird von irgendwelchen Leuten gehackt
und man kann es noch als cooles Gerät verwenden.
Und man kann es noch als cooles Gerät verwenden für Custom-Firmware.
10 Games.
Wollte ich nämlich noch gucken, habe ich ja vorhin extra gespeichert auf dem Tablet.
Genau.
Spiele, die grafisch immer noch gut sind, aber ziemlich alt sind.
Wenn du Prinz Markus bist, baust du ein Haus neben dem Stadioserver, dann hast du deine 45 Millisekunden Reaktionszeit.
Also wenn ich ein Haus neben dem Stadioserver baue und ich nur...
5...
45 Millisekunden Reaktionszeit habe, dann wäre das ganz schön fehl.
Most Video Games look way nicer now than they did back in the 2000s,
but there are some games that hold up pretty damn well.
Today on GameRanks here are 10 games from the 2000s that graphically still hold up.
Starting off with number 10, now this game is unique on this list because it's not really a demanding game
with wild, realistic graphics and heavy-fitting simulation elements.
Instead, Team Fortress 2 seems relevant here because of its stylized look,
which was...
That's true, that's true.
...way more gracefully than other games of that era with more realistic art styles.
Choosing to go with a bright, bold color palette instead of just revisiting the grey and brown more realistic designs of games like Half-Life 2 and Portal
and making unique characters with fun, exaggerated proportions rather than just going with the standard character designs of the time
was a bold move and it definitely paid off here.
The whole vibe was pulled together with the game's maps as well, carrying that aesthetic over into the level design
and creating a more realistic look.
In creating fun, interesting maps that still had...
Leider ist das ein Game, was unter dem Wellfluch von Version 3 leidet,
beziehungsweise irgendwie...
Das bekommt doch eine Relaunch.
Das Game hat es definitiv verdient, weil das hat wenig Liebe bekommen.
...artoonisch look and feel to them that the game has become known for.
Looking at this game, it's clear why modern games like Overwatch have been influenced so much by it.
Both in an aesthetic direction...
Es gibt noch von Siegerl, es gibt noch alte TF2...
...alte TF2-T Fareways.
...althe TF2-T Fareways.
Videos.
Von irgendeinem Laden, der war ja richtig gut damals.
Half-Life 2 war absolut wegweisend, grafisch und vor allem halt von dieser ganzen Physik,
Physikgeschichte.
Aber generell das Gesamtpaket, auch die Gesichter und die Animationen zwar wegweisend, aber
die Farben waren wirklich gut.
Ich meine, es ist krass, was sich in 5 Jahren getan hat, ne?
Das ist Half-Life 1 von 98, wo auch immer.
Das ist Half-Life 1 von 98 und das ist Half-Life 2 von was, 2004?
Ne?
Also was sich in diesen 5-6 Jahren getan hat, ist schon heftig.
So viel hat sich definitiv die letzten 5-6 Jahre nicht getan.
Und Steam, genau.
Ja.
Das sieht doch immer noch ganz gut aus.
Gut, das hat auch ein paar Updates gekriegt, aber trotzdem.
Ja.
and really capturing what it's like, or at least what it was like, 10 years ago.
From the garbage in the streets to the fire escapes,
I actually felt like I was walking around in a living, breathing New York City.
Obviously, yeah, you can get it looking even better with mods,
but we're specifically talking about the base game here.
You did a great job at capturing the feel of different boroughs and neighborhoods as well.
Also including some famous landmarks, such as the Empire State Building,
the White Iron Building, and the Sanctuary of Liberty.
Rockstar has always been good with nailing the settings of their games,
so it's really no surprise that they nailed it here as well.
And at number 7, at least for me, Far Cry 2 definitely felt like a game that was ahead of its time,
both in systems and in visuals.
Yeah, optisch sah das richtig gut aus.
Far Cry 2 bei Release sah richtig gut aus.
Auch diese ganze Geschichte, mit der du irgendwie Bäume anzünden konntest und sowas.
Richtig cool.
Allerdings war das Gameplay von Far Cry 2 überraschend.
Dibbelster Crap.
Ich hab das vielleicht zwei Stunden gespielt, dann wurd's mir zu doof.
Aber man sieht die Ursprünge von Half-Life 3 ganz gut,
weil diese Camp-Einnehmen-Geschichte und sowas, das hattest du in Far Cry 2 auch schon.
Mit Far Cry 1 hat das Ganze übrigens überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun gehabt, ja.
Hat ja auch mit Crytek nichts mehr zu tun gehabt.
Habe ich Half-Life 3 gesagt?
War Far Cry 3.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das sieht verdammt gut aus damals schon.
Ich glaube, Chaos-Theorie habe ich nie gespielt.
Zumindest waren es gute Stelzer-Games.
Mit Ergs-Audio-Effekt. Ja, so muss das sein.
Für ein Xbox-Game, it was really impressive.
And honestly, I still think that even today, it's still impressive.
At number 5, we have Bioshock.
There were a lot of games that tried to have water effects and wet textures be their big thing.
But no one really did it at the time as well as the first Bioshock.
Bioshock, by its very nature, being a game set in an underwater dystopia,
lent itself to these effects super well.
And man, was it really a sight to behold.
Bioshock ist stylmäßig eines der hübschesten Games überhaupt.
Combined with the implementation of normal mapping
made it so you had some really gross but really impressive
instances of wet bricks and metal surfaces
that would reflect really nicely
with a lot of the lighting effects used.
In Einzelheiten vielleicht nicht,
aber vom Style her und der Gesamtlook ist Bioshock eines der hübschesten Spiele überhaupt.
In general is also notable because a lot of it was outside of the standard lighting models.
Genauso wie Mario Galaxy.
Das ist ein komplett anderes Game.
Mario Galaxy hat so ein...
passenden Style,
dass das trotz der Kackauflösung und so einfach gut aussieht.
Du denkst dir bei Games, die versuchen zu übertrieben realistisch zu sein
oder in einer Kategorie von der Grafik viel besser sind als in der anderen,
sticht das immer raus, ja?
Aber du hast Games, sagen wir mal, wie Bioshock, wie Mario Galaxy,
da hast du Games, die sind so gut aus einem Guss,
dass du eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig mitkriegst,
dass du halt auf Grafik auf dem PC guckst.
Und alles musste so aussehen, als ob es gefiltert und durch all das Wasser draußen gefiltert wurde.
Alle diese Effekte kombiniert mit dem Game's tollen Retro-Futurist-Art-Style
wurden für ein wirklich einzigartiges und großartiges Spiel gemacht, das noch heute hält.
Nun, granted, 2K hat eine verbesserte, remastered Version für moderne Konsole und PCs geöffnet.
Und wenn du in 2019 Bioshock spielen willst, dann ist das wahrscheinlich die Version, die du spielen kannst.
Aber noch immer, die original Release sieht immer noch verdammt gut aus.
Vor allem, wenn du dir denkst, wie es 2007 ausgesehen ist.
So alt ist das schon, ey.
Mr. Bubbles!
Crysis sieht heute noch gut aus.
Crysis hatte eine ziemlich große Karte, die sich mit Lusch-Junglen, Wäldern und Bösen befüllt hatte.
Und die hat wirklich coole Effekte verarbeitet, wenn es um die Höhe des Feldes ging,
Motion Blur, Schatten-Rendering und volumetrisches Licht.
Du hattest auch wirklich wilde, umweltfreundliche Interaktionen.
Man konnte einfach nur Bäume mit Pfeifen und so.
Es ist ein wirklich cooles Effekt, das in 2019 immer noch großartig aussieht.
In vielen Fällen fühlt sich das Spiel wie ein...
Danach hat sich Crytek gedacht, ey, lass uns doch 85.000 Studios weltweit aufmachen und pleite gehen.
... und dann kam es raus, dass sie sich in ein Spiel gespunnen haben, um es so zu machen, dass sie sich nicht mehr so gut fühlen.
Eine andere große Grund, warum Crysis so bemerkenswert war, ist, dass es eines der ersten Spiele war, die direkt X10 unterstützt hat,
was die Spiele mit rund 85.000 Schadern ermöglicht hat,
was in 2007 noch ein ziemlich guter Teil der Technik war.
Die Nachfolge, Crysis Warhead, hatte eine deutlich niedrigere Entfernung.
Die Hauptspiele waren besser.
... und die Physiksysteme und die ganzen Visuals.
Aber es sieht immer noch verdammt gut aus, wenn man es mit anderen Spielen vergleicht.
Und es zeigt, dass die Maschine definitiv besser funktioniert.
... und die Maschine definitiv besser funktioniert.
Und jetzt Nummer 3. Uncharted 2 war damals eine grafische Beste.
Einer der Spiele, die man sich an seinen Augen zeigen würde.
Ja, Uncharted, generell die ganze Uncharted-Serie, ist definitiv grafisch auch ein riesen Highlight auf der PS3.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass Uncharted 4 irgendwie schlecht ist oder so, das ist eindeutig noch besser, hübscher.
Aber, Alter, warte, mach ich mal was trinken.
Aber ich muss sagen, Uncharted 2, bei mir,
ich finde ja insgesamt von der Story her und vom Gesamtpaket und so,
mir gefällt immer noch das Einser am besten.
Aber das Zweier hatte eine Sache, was ich selten so gut gesehen habe,
das war die Interaktion von Drake mit der Umgebung.
Ja, du bist gegen die Wand gelaufen, der ist nicht einfach gegen die Wand gelaufen,
der hat seinen Fuß gegen die Wand gemacht, der hat seinen Arm gegen die Wand gestürzt,
der hat sich da angelehnt, der ist in die Kurve, der hat sich um die Ecke gelehnt,
... die Animationen, ...
Also die Animationen waren wirklich das, was für mich, ich meine, der Rest sah auch gut aus, ja,
aber die Animationen waren für das, was für mich Uncharted ausgemacht hat,
und das habe ich selten, Max Payne 3 auch richtig, richtig gut in der Richtung,
aber das habe ich selten so gut gesehen wie in Uncharted.
Der ohne Kohl, das einzige Spiel, was ich für die Vita habe, ist das Uncharted-Game.
Ich war so blöd und habe mir bei Release eine Vita gekauft.
Wann kohlest du wieder, Junge? Jeden Tag?
Bloß halt nicht unbedingt immer on-stream.
Ich muss euch ja sagen, also jetzt mal ehrlich, Leute, so, Uncharted-Grills, ja?
Chloe oder Nadine?
Äh, hieß die überhaupt Nadine?
Ist die Nadine?
Nee, nicht Nadine.
Äh, nicht Nadine.
Äh, Nadine können wir da auch mit rein.
Wie hieß die andere?
Elena, Elena.
Wie komme ich jetzt auf Nadine?
Wisst ihr, was mich, äh, ähm, was mich echt gerade ein bisschen irritiert hat?
Habt ihr die Autovervollständigung gesehen?
Die ich eingegeben habe?
Uncharted, Nadine, Feed?
Was ist mit den Leuten wieder los?
Okay, Leute, Chloe, Nadine oder Elena?
Ja?
Chloe, Beste?
Elena?
Elena, ja, ja, Leute, der Chat weiß Bescheid, der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Elena, eindeutig, ja.
Elena, Beste.
Die Füße.
Jetzt nicht, weil, weil Elena, glaube ich, die angenehmste von allen drei ist.
Sondern auch, weil Elena die hübscheste von allen drei ist.
Das ist in Kombination, da kannst du, was willst du sagen, ja?
Das war es vorher.
Außerdem konnten sie die Präsentation des Spiels verbessern,
durch 564 in-Game-Szenen,
was ein riesiges Verbesserungspunkt war,
gegenüber Drake's Fortune,
das nur 80 war.
Es ist ein wunderschönes Spiel,
und obwohl die späteren Einträge in der Serie
in so vielen Wegen verbessert wurden,
war Uncharted 2 ein...
War ich eigentlich der Einzige, der gedacht hat,
als er hier Flynn das erste Mal gesehen hat,
dass der Typ, äh, quasi in der Story dann dich verarscht?
Ich finde allein schon, wie sie das Charaktermodel gebastelt haben,
war das, sobald du den jetzt gesehen hast, zum ersten Mal klar,
dass der nicht debatet.
Sorry, Spoiler, Spoiler, für ein 10 Jahre altes Game-Ton.
...beiter, durch Remasters und so weiter.
Und dann Nummer 2,
lasst uns über die Resident Evil Remake für Gamecube reden, für einen Moment.
Hä?
Aus der OG-Resident Evil,
sah diese Remake ein Millionen Mal besser aus,
und war auch viel weniger blöd,
und der Gamescom ist, äh, der, der, der, der Gamecube ist ja auch deutlich besser als der PS1.
Da sieht man mal wieder,
also Resident Evil,
die sind ja, die sind ja, ich glaube, das ist die Serie, die bisher am meisten
remaked und remastered wurde, oder?
Ich glaube, Resident Evil wurde jetzt schon so oft remaked, remastered, re-, refurbished,
da weiß ich ja gar nicht mehr, auf welcher Plattform das nicht rausgekommen ist.
...dark hallway with a bunch of windows,
with the only light being from the moon,
as it cast shadows on the wall,
looked so good,
and also felt super creepy,
constantly making you feel uneasy,
and always expecting something that will kill you,
to go crashing through the window.
...to go crashing through the window.
Or when you're outside, or in the lab,
and there are puddles all around,
with light reflecting off of them.
They did a great job with character models as well.
Skyrim, stimmt.
Everyone here looks great,
but I think it's the zombies and other monsters,
that really benefit here.
Zombies looked way more grotesque,
Skyrim kam auch überall raus.
...and the bosses, like Leon, all looked great as well.
I don't think I'll ever get the shot out of my head of Leon
coming on screen right before the boss fight,
where he opens his mouth,
and there's saliva just pouring out of there.
This was recently remastered for current gen consoles,
and besides getting the HD treatment,
there really wasn't much else changed,
it just held up that well.
Finally, at number 1, we have Metal Gear Solid 4,
Guns of the Patriots,
which was released in 2008.
First off, I just wanna point out,
that I think Metal Gear 2 and 3
both hold up graphically as well,
for PS2 games at the time.
Was mich ja immer übelst, übelst irritiert hat,
an Metal Gear Solid 4,
ist die, ähm, die Griechanimation von Snake.
...they looked really good,
and going back to replay them,
they really do stand the test of time.
But back to Metal Gear 4,
I honestly think it could pass for a game
that came out early in this current console generation,
and is also one of the best looking PS3 games,
right next to The Last of Us.
Guckt euch den Hintern an,
in der Griechanimation, Alter.
...which is nice, because this game
has over 8 hours of cutscenes alone,
so you're gonna be looking at it a lot.
Really, Metal Gear Solid 2, 3 and 4
still look damn good up until this day,
because thanks to the general design and art style,
they didn't overdo it,
so there's not tons about them
that can look outdated today.
And that's seemingly by design,
and it works.
Also, we just really freaking love these games.
And those are 10 games from the 2000s
that graphically still hold up.
Ja, hat er echt. Gutes Video.
Ein nices Witt.
20 Overhyped Games, dat floppt.
JavaScript in 5 Minutes.
Evolution of Windows Ads.
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich spoilern will,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich spoilern will.
Ach, komm.
So, jetzt kommt's auf den ersten Punkt.
Komm, wir spoilern uns.
Na, so wirklich spoilern werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht, aber man sieht halt die Welt und ich bin halt echt gespannt, was sie gemacht haben.
War überhaupt nicht beliebt, ne? Im Original Half-Life mochte kaum jemand die Xen-Level.
Xen ist released, ja, es gibt jetzt eine Alpha-Version, wo alles drin ist seit ein paar Tagen.
So richtig final released, die wollen jetzt noch ein paar Bugs fixen, aber es ist alles drin.
Ich muss euch sagen, ich fand die Xen-Levels als Abschluss von Half-Life 1 richtig cool damals, weil es was komplett anderes war.
The Original Half-Life wasn't all that much of a big deal.
I mean, it was just this small game that came out in 1998 that about six people played.
First-person shooter where you hopped into the HEV-Suit of a guy named Gordon Freeman.
They're waiting for you, Gordon, in the test chamber.
Gordon worked for a top-secret corporation called Black Mesa and inadvertently opened a portal to another dimension,
unleashing otherworldly beings that ran amok and turned the base into a warzone.
The whole thing was okay, I guess, but it only really ended up with a small cost.
The game was a great result, following which still lives on to this day.
So if you haven't played it, it's no big deal, you didn't really miss much.
You know, the saddest thing too is that there's some people probably watching this who didn't pick up on my sarcasm.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, die meisten Leute haben es wahrscheinlich wieder nicht gecheckt.
Das ist eh geil.
Wenn du was total Offensichtliches schreibst, wo du es halt so übertreibst, dass es halt klar ist, dass du das eigentlich nicht so meinst,
hast du dann gleich die ersten Leute, die dann auf Twitter ankommen,
und dann sagst du, das stimmt jetzt so aber nicht.
Ja, das war...
Das war auch Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Anyway, point is, after fighting his way to the core of the Black Mesa base,
Gordon then had to cross over to Zen to confront the alien leader on his own turf.
And the quality of these last few levels is something that's been in contention for years.
Ich mochte die.
And it's something we've been anxiously waiting to see how it gets carried across in this remake.
Yeah, and before we go further, can we please just clear up the difference between a remake and a remaster,
before I hit someone in the face with a crowbar.
A remake is taking something and rebuilding it entirely from scratch.
A remaster is taking something that exists and only improving the sound and visual quality.
Black Mesa is a remake, not a remaster.
And if you called it otherwise, well, you're dead to me.
Ranting aside, also keep in mind that this is still in public beta, even though it's by and large finished.
Which means you're gonna see some stuff you're not supposed to see.
Like this, where I fell through the map for some reason.
Dude.
Vital signs.
Pretty kill.
All in all, though, it's playable from start to finish, and that's what matters.
Personally, I never thought Xen was over-
Ich mein, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, es ist, es ist Source Engine, ja.
...that good, and when I replay Half-Life, every time I finished Lambda Core and got to these levels, I'd usually just stop playing.
Ich nicht, ich hab's immer durchgespielt.
There's always been this really weird demographic of Half-Life fanboys who always act like Xen is some kind of misunderstood series of levels.
And as if the people who don't like them just don't get it or something, like you've gotta have some kind of high IQ to understand what Valve wants.
Ich mochte Xen levels.
Ich mochte Xen-Level.
Das ist aber überhaupt kein Problem gewesen. Du konntest auf jeder Plattform quick-safen.
Also das waren ja noch Games, wo man quick-save machen konnte.
Dieser Crap-Film, Alter.
Er sieht richtig hübsch aus.
Der erste Bereich, in den du eingestiegen bist, sieht einfach großartig aus.
Mit diesem tollen Drahtraum und einer serenen Vista.
Mit großen Kreaturen, die wie riesige Sting-Röhren fliegen, die in der Distanz fliegen.
Es gibt auch diesen tollen Ambient-Soundtrack, der sich fast mit den hübschen Untertönen des Kapitels befindet.
Die Musik wurde von einem Jungen namens Joel Nielsen komponiert,
dessen Arbeit in den anderen Kapiteln, finde ich, manchmal ein bisschen unangenehm ist.
Aber die meiste seiner Sachen in diesen Xen-Kapiteln sind wirklich gut.
Sie haben es irgendwie geschafft, diese Dinge...
Ist das cool?
Das sieht gut aus.
Noch nie von Xen gehört, gab es das früher auch schon.
Das war ganz normal in Half-Life drinne.
Half-Life 1 war schon immer das erste...
So drei Viertel des Games waren halt auf der Erde und das letzte Viertel war halt hier auf Xen.
War schon seit Release so.
Nur, dass es halt im Black Mesa Remake bisher nicht drinne war.
Das hängt von den Böden- oder großen Stalaktiten ab.
Dann kombiniert man es alles mit diesen wunderschönen Licht- und Wasser-Effekten
und man hat ein richtig gut aussehendes Spiel.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten zu spielen.
Das kommt zu den Kosten der Performance und du kannst erwarten das Spiel hier und da zusammenzuschauen.
Aber ich glaube künstlich sind diese neuen Chapters einfach fantastisch und ich kann nicht wirklich den Art-Stil falsch machen.
Es ist definitiv anders als bei den ursprünglichen Shovels, aber ich glaube das ist gar nicht so ein schlechtes Ding.
Weil die meisten dieser Shovels ziemlich unverrückend und ein wenig generisch sind.
In was einfach ist aber effektiv verändert wird,
Das Long Jump Modul ist nun zweimal auf den Spacepark eingeschaltet, was viel mehr Sinn macht, als den Crouch und den Jump zu drücken, wie im originalen Spiel.
Und du wirst diese Mechanik gut nutzen, ehrfurchtlos von Plattform zu Plattform zu fliegen.
Aber auch während des Kampfes, weil es einen ziemlich handigen Dodge-Move macht, während der Boss-Fights.
Also, direkt am Anfang gibt es sehr wenig zu verraten, außer, dass es ausgesprochen mehr aquatisch aussieht, als es Alien manchmal macht.
Was ich wirklich mag an den meisten dieser ersten Phasen, ist, dass es einen viel besseren Job macht,
dass Black Mesa wirklich diesen Ort besucht hat, bevor Gordon herkommt.
Das ist etwas, was sie nur wirklich in dem originalen Spiel betrachtet haben.
Wenn du hier und da über die selben menschlichen Körbe kommst.
In Black Mesa kommst du über verschiedene Camps und Makeshift-Labs,
die wirklich beobachten, dass die Lambda-Team hier einen Shop setzten.
Dann, als du tiefer und tiefer in diese Läufe gehst, werden diese Ausflüge viel weniger freundlich,
beobachten, dass du jetzt wirklich in unverzichtbarem Territory bist.
Mein einziges, was mich an diesen ersten Phasen beobachtet hat, ist die Überausgabe der Hound-Eier.
Ich meine, es gab einige dieser Dinge im originalen Spiel, aber nicht so viele.
Und außerdem gibt es sogar ein paar neue Varianten,
insbesondere die kleineren, die explodieren, wenn getötet werden.
Und auch eine größere Armut-Kind.
Diese Sache auch, wenn du all diese Tripwires verhindern musst, ist einfach furchtbar.
Aber nur in Bezug auf die Basis-Logik, macht es keinen Sinn.
Warum würde jemand all diese Zeit auf Tripwires setzen,
in einem randomen Tunnel,
auf einem interdimensionalen Bord-Welt?
Ja, sowas darf man sich da nicht fragen.
Diese ersten paar Bereiche sind ziemlich erfreulich und kreativ,
kombinierend mit Plattformen, Kampf und einigen Basis-Puzzle-Solven.
Man bewegt sich auf eine gute Art und Weise und fühlt sich niemals aufgedrückt.
Die ersten Impressionen, wie sie sagen, sind das Wichtigste, und Zen ist ein guter Start.
Danach ist der Boss-Fight gegen Gonark.
Und wiederum, diese ganze Bereiche sind wirklich visuell beeindruckend.
Vielleicht sogar mehr als das erste Kapitel.
In Wahrheit, die erste Zeit, als ich in diese Bereiche geblieben bin,
Ich meine, es ist immer noch Sauce, ja?
Ja.
Ja, Serious Max, der war richtig gut.
Richtig gut.
Er hat mich an etwas geschlagen oder mich in den Kopf geraten.
Also, das könnte ein Problem sein auf Hard-Mode.
Wie vorher, nachdem du ein bisschen Schaden verursacht hast,
fliegt sie weg und du besuchst sie.
Aber im originalen Spiel war es ziemlich schnell, wenn du sie wieder findest.
In Wahrheit, der ganze Kampf war in 10 oder 15 Minuten vorbei.
Aber in Black Mesa spielst du stattdessen ein bisschen Katze und Maus,
fast nur mit den Beinen, damit sie dich nicht beschleunigt.
Ich würde sagen, dieser ganze Kapitel dauert leicht 30 bis 45 Minuten,
und es ist nicht bis zum Ende, wo du endlich wieder einen Rundweg nimmst.
Dann spielt es wieder so, wie es vorher war.
Ja gut, die bricht da jetzt ein, das war ja im Original auch so.
... mit welchem etwas mehr als eine Verrücktheit.
Und du schlägst einfach ihre riesige Schachtel mit allem, was du hast,
beobachtend darauf, wie sie sich immer wieder auf dich schlägt,
wegen ihrer gigantischen Hitboxen.
Dieser ganze Kapitel war okay.
All das, was zwischen dem 1-on-1 mit dem Gonarch ging, war definitiv das Highlight,
sobald die Konfrontation einfach so fühlt wie die gleiche von 1998.
Interloper ist dort, wo es sich alles ausbreitet.
Es beginnt zumindest ziemlich schnell.
Aber es ist auch ziemlich gut,
zum Beispiel in der ersten Hälfte dieses Kapitels
siehst du ein bisschen die Kultur der Vortigaunts,
als du durch einige ihrer Wälder fliegst,
um diese Jungs von Alien-Grunts und den Alien-Kontrollern zu retten.
Die beiden, die die Möglichkeit haben, die Vortigaunts gegen dich zu schießen.
Nur wenn du denkst, dass du diese Alien-Kontrollern nicht mehr hassen würdest,
machen sie dir so ein bisschen Bullshit.
Visuell differenziert sich dieser ganze Kapitel auch,
und du fliegst durch einige mehr alien-sehende Landschaften,
fährst nach dem Meer und dann durch einige Dank-Kabinen.
Ja, Dank.
Das öffnet sich ein wenig,
und du wirst von einigen oder mehr Gargantuanen gefangen.
Und du hast einfach einen armen Arsch.
Längs über diese bottomlessen Kasmen.
Ich meine, das ist ziemlich süß.
Vergleiche das mit dem Original, wo du diese einzelne Gargantua auslitterst.
Ich meine, diese ganze Sequenz war ein definitiver Verbesserung.
Und hatte eigentlich einen Sinn für Urgenz und Intensität.
Dann kommst du in die Fabrik,
und das ist, wo es sich um Scheisse handelt,
als du diese unendliche Reihe von Konveierbelten bewegst.
Du machst einiges an Blättern,
und hast ein Hundert Furze-Felder auf dem Weg.
Nicht zu erwähnen, diese verrückten Serien,
die anhand von Puzzles angemeldet wurden,
um die ganzen Arme abzuschleppen,
und sie haben es in die Fläche gelegt.
Das sind diese Kabel.
Es ist einfach monoton.
Und es war die Aree, wo ich die meisten der Verwirrungen auch erlebt habe.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was hier gerade passiert ist.
Ansonsten hat es mich über 90 Minuten gedauert, um durch den Titel zu kommen, aber es könnte 90 Stunden gewesen sein, weil das war, wie es sich fühlte.
Die letzte Partie ist noch schlimmer. Es hat dich in diesen exklusiv langsamen Elevator gewechselt,
als die Alien-Kontrollen einfach immer mehr in die Welt spazieren und dich mit Projektilen aus allen Angeln verbreiten.
Ich würde sagen, es ist wahrscheinlich eine der schlimmsten Dinge in der ganzen Remake.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich es hasse, weil Hass ist so ein starkes Wort.
Stark wie deine Mamas Hüftenmuskeln.
Aber du beginnst wirklich zu sehen, dass es in diesem Titel nicht mehr so gut ist, und diese Momente fühlen sich nur ein bisschen überrascht an.
Einige der Texte, die du in diesem Titel arbeitest, sind wirklich schlecht.
Schau dir das hier an. Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an etwas von Gunman Chronicles.
Es gibt diese Kristalle in diesem Titel, die dein Glüh-on-Gun-Energie immer wieder überladen.
Ein bisschen wie wie der Gravity-Gun in Half-Life 2 überladen wurde,
was ich glaube, war der Art des Level-Designers, um zu kompensieren, dass man so viel Bullshit an den Spieler macht.
Aber diese gesamte Werkstatt in diesem Titel ist einfach ziemlich furchtbar,
und ich musste eigentlich einfach das Spiel nach dem Spiel beenden und einen Pause nehmen, um meine Hände wieder zusammen zu machen.
Ich war so irritiert, dass ich bereit war, eine Katze in den Gesicht zu fressen.
Interloper, denke ich, war immer einer der schlimmsten Titel des originalen Spiels.
Ich denke, es ist wahrscheinlich so schlecht wie Honoria, aber zumindest hat es nicht über eine Stunde gedauert, um es durchzuführen.
Wenn die gesamte Intention dieses Remake-Titels war, meine Schmerzen mit dieser Teil des Spiels zu verringern, dann...
Mission accomplished.
Ich werde das Ende-Boss und das Ende nicht verspüren, obwohl die meisten schon wissen, was das ist,
aber ich sage, dass sie es dankbar für das Finale umdrehen, also drei aus vier Kapiteln sind nicht so schlecht.
Einer von ihnen war wohl weniger schlecht als der andere.
Der letzte Boss-Fight wurde etwas wiedergearbeitet, um es weniger unangenehm zu machen.
Die hohe Gravität des originalen Spiels ist weg, also fühlt es sich nicht so an, als würdest du unter Wasser fliegen.
Und der Boss schießt nicht diese Teleportation-Portale ab.
Ja, also der Boss-Fight war wirklich so eine Sache.
Es ist auch so, dass das Long-Jump-Modul zu gut genutzt wird. Es ist auch so, dass das Long-Jump-Modul zu gut genutzt wird.
Es ist auch so, dass das Long-Jump-Modul zu gut genutzt wird.
In Half-Life Wild...
Das hat sich sehr schwammig angefühlt.
...bein redone in der Source-Endung.
Und du wusstest doch überhaupt nicht, wo du ihn richtig treffen musst, also...
Ja, das war nicht so richtig fertig.
I am impressed.
Das Einzige, worum ich nicht sicher bin, ist die Länge all dessen.
Die originalen Xen-Chapters hätten vielleicht eine Stunde oder so gedauert.
Die Xen-Chapters in Black Mesa haben mich knapp zu vier gedauert.
Habe ich gut?
Das ist wahrscheinlich nach den zehn oder so Stunden, die es dauerte, um so weit zu beginnen.
Das ist auch gut.
Es ist eine gute Länge, weil es den Preis und die Zeit, die sie verwendet haben, beurteilt.
Der Herr weiß, dass es lange genug dauerte.
Aber ich bin nicht sicher, ob es gut mit der vorliegenden Kampagne passt.
Ich meine, ich würde es von Anfang an spielen müssen, aber ich denke, es könnte das Ende des Spiels
sogar noch blöder aussehen, als es es zu Beginn war.
Ich habe einfach nicht...
Vilden braucht nicht all das zu hören.
Er ist ein sehr trainierter Profi.
Black Mesa ist ein Spiel, in dem es sich um seine Teilen handelt.
Ich meine, wenn man sich nur den Xen selbst anschaut, was ich schon gemacht habe,
ist es einfach, die ganze Sache zu knippen und all diese Fehler zu finden.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist die Remake überhaupt einfach unglaublich.
Ich denke, das ist das Größte, was ich in den letzten Jahren gelernt habe,
mit meinen Erfahrungen mit diesem Spiel.
Von jemandem, der es überhaupt nicht mag,
zu jemandem, der das Potenzial gesehen hat,
bis zum Schluss zu jemandem, der es einfach bemerken kann,
als Resultat von Leuten, die auf etwas aufregend gearbeitet haben,
seit über einer Dekade.
Und weißt du was?
Ich kann das nicht wirklich nicht mögen.
Natürlich würde ich nie jemandem empfehlen,
dieses Spiel zu spielen, bevor sie Vanilla Half-Life spielen.
Aber als Remake eines der grundlegendsten Erst-Personen-Schützers
der Zeit ist,
denke ich, dass Crowbar Collective so gut gearbeitet hat,
wie jemand es tun könnte,
und das ganze zu Leben bringen könnte.
Wir haben vielleicht nicht Vanilla Half-Life 3,
aber zumindest haben wir das.
Ah, pfff, keine Ahnung.
Nochmal neu on Stream.
Da müssen wir aber 14 Stunden oder so Half-Life spielen.
Na gut, ich kenne das Game.
Sagen wir mal so 10 Stunden vielleicht.
Komm, wir gucken noch ein bisschen Windows-Werbung.
Das ist bestimmt übelst cringe.
Oh ne!
Die Ad kenne ich.
Ja, die ist wirklich relativ bekannt.
Das ist eigentlich nur richtig Fremdschämen, die Werbung da.
Aber generell war viel Software-Werbung und Spiele-Werbung damals übelst zum Fremdschämen.
Kennt noch jemand die Link to the Past Super Nintendo Werbung?
Link ist da super...
Ne, wie ging das?
Darke Mächte, dunkle...
Das war auch so übelst fail.
Die Super Nintendo Zelda Werbung in Deutschland, ey.
Drachen und Monster und Fantasy.
Irgendwie so ging das doch.
Das war richtig fail.
Das ist so...
Oh, das ist so kaputt.
Paint, sogar mit Paint.
Eine Uhr.
Sogar eine Uhr.
Eine Uhr ist dabei.
Das ist der Ballmer, oder?
Das ist der junge Ballmer, glaube ich.
Ich erkenne es nicht so richtig, weil die Qualität so schlecht ist.
Oh, kaputt.
Oh nein, das ist das Schlimmste.
Das ist die cringigste, ohne Scheiß, das ist die cringigste Software-Werbung, die ich je gesehen habe.
Das ist ein Video, das geht normalerweise, das geht irgendwie 40 Minuten oder so.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Werbevideo, was sie gedreht haben.
Das geht lange, ja.
Und das Schlimme ist, ich glaube, dass es jetzt auch da aussieht, die fangen jetzt gleich an zu singen.
Irgendwie, this is Windows 386.
Das ist so zum Fremdschämen, Alter.
Das ist so schrecklich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das durchhalte.
Lotus.
Ohohoho.
Oh, das tut weh.
Es schmerzt.
Paint Champ.
Es tut echt weh.
Huge AxelCrafts.
Noch mehr AxelCrafts.
Hahaha.
Windows.
Microsoft.
Ah, ja.
A new girl took maternity leave.
We all said, get Sue back.
Oh, whatever happened to my old typewriter?
We got rid of it years ago.
Coffee?
Yes, thanks.
Die Musik dabei.
Leute, wisst ihr, was ich bei diesem Bild denke?
Denkt mir nur ein Wort.
Neuland.
Make software that makes computers work for you.
So, you've used Microsoft.
For as long as I've been using computers.
Microsoft, making it easier.
Wow.
Excellent.
Ach so, das war ein Livestream aus dem Bundestag.
Verstehe.
Was geht jetzt ab?
Oh, Windows 95.
Ja, das kenn ich noch.
Das kommt mir auch noch bekannt vor.
Okay, das ist jetzt halbwegs irgendwie,
schon halbwegs normale Werbung irgendwie.
So nach dem Motto, Leute benutzen Computer und freuen sich,
wie geil ihr Computer mit Windows ist.
Sag mal.
Das ist die gleiche Excel-Grafik,
die sie bei Windows 368 gezeigt haben, oder?
Das ist doch genau die gleiche Excel-Grafik,
nur mit mehr Farben.
Der Windows 95 Release Dance.
Oh ne, der kommt bestimmt auch noch.
CD.
Oh, zwei FPS.
Nochmal zwei FPS-Videos.
Bisschen verwirrt.
Oh nein, es ist der Windows 98 Dance.
Oh.
Das gab es ja auch noch.
Das habe ich schon voll verdrängt.
By the way, I believe in winners and losers
and especially the freedom to fail.
Who, him?
Who?
Him?
Me?
Das ist, das ist Ballmer und Bill Gates, ja.
Internet Explorer.
Oh, jetzt geht es ab hier.
Und Formel 1 und Science und Spiele und alles.
Und es explodiert.
Was man damit alles machen kann.
Oh mein Gott, man kann sein Bildschirm vergrößern.
Mit einer Lupe.
Und es gibt irgendwie Dinosaurier und Startknöpfe und Internet Explorer
und Ordner und Smiley's und Schmetterlinge und Mauszeiger und
nochmal Internet Explorer, Office, Senden, Microsoft.
Ah ja, alles klar.
What?
Die Logik habe ich jetzt nicht, habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Hallo, ich war im Knast, habe Leute umgebracht.
Ich benutze nur Windows 98.
Weil Windows und Fenster im Knast, oder was?
Microsoft Windows XP.
Das ist eigentlich richtig, richtig Next Level Brain, die Werbung gewesen.
Oh, jetzt kommt, jetzt darf der Ballmer wieder rumschreien von Windows XP.
Watch why I make Windows XP the center of my home.
So, sowas passiert halt, wenn einer der Chefs der Meinung ist,
er kann Werbung am besten selbst machen.
Alter.
Die haben sich da sowas von übertrieben, ey.
Aber eins muss man sagen, man muss ihn zugutehalten,
es war halt irgendwie abgedrehte,
jetzt nicht unbedingt so massenkompatibel gemachte Werbung, ja.
Es war halt einfach abgedreht bescheuert.
Hatte mit Windows XP, wenn man ehrlich sagt,
hat mit Windows XP, wenn man ehrlich sagt,
überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Aber es war halt da.
Microsoft.
Wow.
Our helpdesk calls dropped significantly
and our stocks up over 40% since the start of the year.
Goodbye Windows 9X, hello Windows XP.
That's why I don't do Windows for home and business users.
How much did you get?
300.
A thousand.
Oh, nicht schon wieder.
It's just 99 dollars.
Schon wieder.
Why don't you tell us what's new in IT?
Try to keep it short.
Oh, well, we just implemented DFS and a new SAN.
And also we enabled shadow copy for shared folders on our file servers.
It enabled users to get back lost documents on their own without calling IT.
And it'll save us hundreds of thousands of dollars.
It'll do what?
With new Windows Server 2.0.
Natürlich.
You have a new Windows Server 2.0.
You can do more.
Na, klar.
So wird es gewesen sein.
Windows Vista.
Das ist jetzt, man sieht man schon, das ist eindeutig ne Werbung, neuere Style Werbung.
Das wird auf hip gemacht, ist halbwegs ordentlich geschnitten, hat hier irgendwie so ne freudige
Musik im Hintergrund.
Und auch ne Sache, die wir jetzt noch mal machen.
Ne, die man feststellt, so in der Werbung, die später kommt, ist, sie versuchen halt
die Benutzergruppe, das haben sie vorher auch schon versucht, hat man in der Werbung
gesehen, aber jetzt so richtig, dass die Benutzergruppe möglichst divers aussieht.
Ja, du siehst dunkelhäutige Leute Windows benutzen, du siehst Asiaten Windows benutzen,
du siehst weiße Leute, Mexikaner, alles mögliche.
Und das ist ja so wie Werbung aktuell aussieht.
Also ab da war die Werbung halt so halbwegs Mainstream.
Davor war einfach beknackt die Werbung.
Ribbon Bars.
Das ist ja auch so ein Ding, was Microsoft verkackt hat, ja.
Die haben das damals angepriesen, als sie Ribbon Bars in Office eingeführt haben, als
der neue beste Weg ever, wie man Interfaces gestaltet.
Ihre eigenen Sachen haben sie nur spärlich umgebaut, teilweise gar nicht.
Und es gab bis zum Schluss keine gescheite Library, um Anwendungen mit Ribbon Bars zu
machen.
Guck mal, sogar der Dalai Lama verwendet Windows Vista.
Oh, Desktop Widgets, ja die haben sie ja wieder abgeschafft mittlerweile.
Also ich rechne ja damit ab.
Also ich rechne ja damit, dass 2020, ähm, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie 2020 ein
neues Windows ankündigen, aber sie werden garantiert, also garantiert, soweit, soweit
ich denke, garantiert ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, ähm, weil das Jahr passt einfach
gut.
Das Jahr, also 2020 ist einfach ein gutes Jahr, um quasi, ähm, nicht unbedingt ein
neues Windows, aber auch so ein Windows 10, ich sag jetzt einfach mal billig, so ein Windows
20 zu machen im Endeffekt.
Ein neues Windows.
Ein neues Jahrzehnt.
Ähm, irgendwie sowas.
Die machen da gar...
Ich würde mich sehr wundern, wenn die nix machen 2020 mit Windows-Benahmung.
Windows 2.
Das wäre EA-Logik.
Aber ab jetzt muss man sagen, ab jetzt ist die Werbung halt nicht mehr cringe, ab jetzt
ist die Werbung aber auch gleichermaßen irgendwie langweilig, oder?
Die ist jetzt einfach so normal.
Und langweilig, die Werbung.
Davor war die Werbung viel mehr cringe.
Aber auch irgendwie unterhaltsamer.
Vielleicht kommt da Pedobear.
Ha!
Media Center.
Jetzt haben sie wieder eingestampft mittlerweile.
Yeah!
Windows Vista!
Legend!
Fünf Monate lang schön.
Poc, Big Brain Sub.
Oh, Windows 7.
Haha, genau!
Wir haben Windows nur gemacht, um uns zu erfreuen.
Das ist genauso wie Fortnite.
Das ist genau wie Fortnite.
Das ist genau wie Fault House 76 erzählt, dass das Monatsabo nur auf Community-Feedback
eingeführt wurde...
mhm.
... und rein kosmetische Gegenstände gegen Pet to Win Items ausgetauscht wurden.
Auch weil's die Community wollte.
Natürlich.
Magic.
Wow.
Komplette Magie.
Es gibt ja immer noch Leute, die sich weigern, von Windows 7 aus umzusteigen.
Aber 2020 ist vorbei, Leute.
Mit Windows 7.
Oh je.
Ja, so hast du dich mit Windows 8 gefühlt, ungefähr.
Wollen die uns ernsthaft erzählen, dass ihnen jetzt aufgefallen ist, dass Windows XP so dermaßen schlecht war, dass man Windows 8 verwenden sollte?
Ich glaube, es ist eine schlechte Werbung, sein eigenes Produkt zu dissen, um das neue verkaufen zu wollen.
Oh ja, Kacheln, da haben wir drauf gewartet.
Aid.
Genau.
Die Werbung, die hat mich auch damals schon genervt.
Ja, ich kann Melonen durchschneiden auf dem Tablet. Endlich.
Reimagined.
Ja, ohne Desktop, bei einem Desktop-Betriebssystem.
Das war ein absolut Next-Level-Big-Brain-Move von Microsoft.
Reimagined.
Diese Kinder müssen keine Passwörter erinnern, oder sich um Sicherheit interessieren.
Für sie ist jeder Screen zu bewegen.
Und Webseiten sollen gescribbelt und geteilt werden.
Sie werden ihre Geräte erwarten.
Was haben die Kinder mit Windows?
Was hat das mit Windows 10 zu tun?
Ich kann es doch übertreiben.
Ja, klar, klar, ja, gut.
Ich meine, man kann ja...
Die letzte Werbung war schon wieder zu übertrieben jetzt.
Das ist halt die Werbung, die funkt es heutzutage.
Ich bin mir sicher, sie haben das analysiert und sind auch zu diesem Schluss gekommen, ja.
Aber, irgendwie ist das Werbung, die finde ich langweilig.
Dann habe ich doch lieber Ballmer und Bill Gates dancen zu einer neuen Windows-Version.
So, Leute, ich muss mal dringend aufs Klo.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal die neue...
Was hat der Elektro-Buben für ein neues Video?
My sister-in-law is visiting from Australia and...
I'm kidding, she's cool.
She brought her a special hair dryer from there that's apparently the only type in existence in the entire universe that does the magic on...
Schwester Rose, zwei Monate, Twitch Prime, danke schön.
Big brain sub.
Her hair.
The problem is that it runs on 240 volts and here we have 120 volts.
Tja, Loop-Land, Loop-Country.
Yeah, she's Australian while my wife is Canadian.
It's because we are all Iranian, of course, but every one of us moved to a different spot in the world.
The end.
Maybe I should do a Draw My Life or something in my other channel, Meditation.
Anyway, my sister-in-law ended up in Australia and now she needs like 230 volts to run her hair dryer.
What she needs is a power adapter and so she bought this.
Yes, this is an adapter, but it only converts to Australium.
It's an Australian plug shape into a North American plug shape and in fact, this thing was purchased from China, so it already had an Australian adapter on top of it.
What?
Was ist das für ein Craft?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Mehr Adapter in Adapter.
It already had an Australian adapter on top of it.
You could directly connect it.
It doesn't matter.
All we need is something to convert 120-volt AC to 240 volts.
Of course, I'm not blaming her for not knowing.
She's a senior planner and project manager with a background in chemical engineering.
Ja, gut.
Als Projektmanager kann man ja solche einfachen Sachen nicht verstehen.
Das kann ich auch verstehen, ja.
I am the electrical engineer.
So all I'm asking is to trust me for once.
I earn my skills from experience.
If you also like to learn a new skill or improve it.
Jetzt schockt er sich gleich wieder mit irgendwas.
Ah, erst mal sell out.
Where you can get two months of free service.
Und als nächstes kommt noch ExpressVPN.
You can take many of the thousands of classes available.
More on that later.
But seriously, the best gift you can give yourself.
For anybody is knowledge.
So yes, of course, you can plug this into the 120-volt AC line and it will turn on.
But at half the voltage, we only get a quarter of the power out of it.
So it won't heat or blow enough.
Of course, there are tons of electronics out there that come with their own switching power supplies.
Like a laptop or a mobile phone charger that supports the entire input voltage range.
For these, all you need to do is to adapt their plug.
But things like an iron or a hairdryer don't have their power adapter.
So this is a transformer that outputs 240 volts.
You simply plug this into the 120-volts.
Was ist aus deinem 10G-Home-Server nass geworden?
Der läuft?
Plug your hairdryer in and turn this on.
Und dann geht das nicht.
Oh.
Ich weiß, es ist immer gestellt, aber es ist geil gestellt.
But this needed a thousand watts.
There are a thousand watts, 240 volts.
Step up track.
Nicht, dass der Smoked.
Der Smoked natürlich echt, aber der weiß, dass er das macht.
Transformers, you could buy.
But for that price, you could buy a whole new hairdryer.
You can borrow our hairdryer, you know.
I don't need it.
It's the only one that does it for you, eh?
You know, you just look fine the way you are.
I'm sure we can find something similar.
No, I didn't buy my degrees.
I want to make it work.
Fine.
Hey.
Actually, we do have 200-volt or 240-volt AC at home.
In North America, we run most things at 120-volt AC.
But we also do realize that for very high-power stuff like the laundry dryer or the electric stove,
running them on 120-volt AC would draw tons of current.
So those things run between 220-volt phases at my home, 120 degrees apart,
to make around 205 volts AC.
So for the same power, it means half the current.
I heard that some homes, they invert one phase 180 degrees to make an actual 240-volt AC.
Is that true?
I'm in a house now that's being renovated.
Let's check the voltage.
This is the oven outlet.
The voltage reading here will show us if the phases are 120 degrees out or 180 degrees out.
Let's check.
Holy .
Piece of .
The meter was on current.
Always make sure it is on voltage before you measure voltage.
Hopefully it can still measure voltage.
Oh, there you go.
We have 240-volt AC, which means our 120-volt AC lines are 180 degrees out of phase.
So it is true.
They wire the houses differently.
And the apartments.
What's going on here?
I hear some electric hissing and arcs.
What the hell is going on here?
OK.
It seems like they've cut a piece of wire here.
And the water dripping from that pipe got into that hole and the wire is shorting.
NA security.
The house from the kitchen.
Water is dripping.
I open this so the water gets out and the wire should be down here.
I'll try.
It burns anything.
Here.
I found a wire and pulled it out of the ceiling.
I think I need to do something about it.
I wish I know which fuse was connected to this guy.
Where is he actually?
Oh, I guess when the universe doesn't want a house to burn down, it sends me over.
So that I discover the short.
Well, I don't have my tools with me to disconnect the wire.
So for now I'll just disconnect the main fuse.
Geez.
Now how do I find my way out?
There we go.
Contractors can come and fix it.
I was lucky to be there and to catch it.
Imagine if I just filmed there and didn't catch the issue.
Who would ever believe that it wasn't my fault the house burned down?
Anyway, I should be able to tap him.
Oh ne, jetzt macht er wieder sein Herd ab.
Pull it back a little bit.
Das macht er ja öfters mal.
Thanks to the stupid design of the outlet, I can pull it back a little bit and expose
the high voltage lines.
Let's see what voltage we...
F***.
Ow.
What the f*** was that?
Pff.
Stepped on stupid spaghetti down here.
I have to clean it up.
Okay, let's do it.
F***.
Oh man.
Stupid sketchy tight space.
Anyway, these two are the two phases that are 206 volts different and this one is neutral.
That's 120 volts different.
So it means that our two phases are 120 degrees apart.
Was macht er da?
Einen Haartrockner anschließen.
Einen 240 Volt Haartrockner anschließen.
Dangerous here.
So maybe the perfect location for her.
I'm joking of course.
I'll break my back trying to pull her body out of there.
And why do we need to go back there anyway when we can't pull one of these heating elements
out.
See if I probe it and turn this on.
Will er da jetzt den Haartrockner dran anschließen oder was?
And these elements can run over a thousand watts so this output is pretty adequate for
me.
It's a shame I can't plug this directly in there.
Beste Taktik.
Erstmal am Herd den Haartrockner anschließen.
Ich krieg ja immer ein bisschen Panik, wenn er da mit den Händen dran rumfuddelt.
Da weiß man immer nie, ob er jetzt sich mal wieder schockt oder nicht.
Vor allem wenn du dich da dran schockst, wird's halt langsam lebensgefährlich, ne?
Here's an idea.
I remember.
For some reason all the outlets in my kitchen
have a separate phase going to every outlet.
See?
There.
I think it's because we are running high-power appliances in the kitchen and it's wiser to
run them from different phases not to overload the line.
So if I can plug the hairdryer between two phases, I'll be in business.
I just need some plugs and outlets.
Was macht Elektro Boom hier?
Wir gucken uns das Video an.
Here we are.
The hairdryer of the outlet is connected to the live –
even if we just plug in one of them, it is still safe to touch the other one because it's
not connected anywhere.
Now if we connect the hairdryer –
ah, sh***
I was wrong.
If you plug in a hairdryer that's on, the live voltage will travel through the hairdryer
to the other plug, so this is live now.
It's only safe if you plug both of them in first and then plug the hairdryer.
Ah.
Sieh, es funktioniert wie ein Charme.
Ich habe es wieder gemacht, Leute.
Wir haben gerade ein neues gekauft, oder?
Ich dachte, das war das Einzige, was noch besser funktioniert.
Ich habe euch die perfekte Lösung gefunden.
Zumindest fühle ich mich ein bisschen besser,
wenn ich weiß, dass dieses Video von Skillshare gesponsert wird.
Eine Gemeinschaft von Leuten mit allmählichen Wissen und Fähigkeiten
von Business, Woodworking...
Von dem gucke ich jedes Video.
Ich finde den immer richtig gut.
Richtig nice gemacht.
Vor allem, was bei den Videos von ihm halt wirklich sehr nice ist,
man lernt was bei.
Vielleicht bei dem eben jetzt ein bisschen weniger.
Bei den anderen, man lernt bei jedem Video was.
Man lernt sogar bei dem Video was bei,
wo er mit seiner Tochter zusammen Spielzeug modifiziert hat,
was Elektroschocks verteilt.
Da lernt man überall was bei.
Oder?
Das da, woran er Dusche leckt.
Also kann ich nur empfehlen zu abonnieren.
Das ist jemand, der hat seine 3,15 Millionen Abos komplett zurecht.
Ja.
So Leute, jetzt gehe ich aufs Klo und dann Mittagessen.
Das heißt, muss jetzt off.
Aber, morgen ist ja auch noch ein Tag, vielleicht heute Abend.
Mal gucken.
Vielleicht spielen wir nachher sogar Black Mesa.
Müssen wir mal gucken, beziehungsweise die Xen-Levels.
Und wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.
Tschüss.
Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr.